I didn't say you see well that that's
why we're argument I guess cuz I'm right
you're wrong
uh-oh look at that move Queen takes f7
h5 Falls with check and you can resign I
don't know I don't want to say I told
you so
it's all I'm not going to like what my
wife says when she's like I don't want
to point out that I told you this guess
who's back back again Danny's back with
his his friend guess who's back guess
who's back we didn't even rehearse that
we did it all so ready for another three
and a half hours of speech chess
championship action who's up next let's
bring a who's who's behind door number
two Johnny
Vladislav artemyev and Alexander Grisham
two of the best chess players in Russia
on the planet the six seed is in many
ways the underdog in the match yeah it's
interesting to see that because he's a
high rated player of the two but Cooke
has the experience on his side he's
played in many speeches champion as you
see his overall record four and three
and his Rory's favorite is the quicker
time controls at the L plus one and the
one plus one and he's a two game
favorite overall yeah it's interesting
again the six seed is based on the feed
a blitz rankings but our probability
predictor smarter chess predictions have
Grichuk as a favorite heading into this
and our Power Rankings kind of say why
right as you just said Grichuk has a
four and three lifetime record he's been
doing this thing for a while like Levon
Aronian and his overall SEC ranking
being number four by time control you
look at him right kind of in the middle
of the pack right Grichuk has made it to
the semi finals a couple times but never
made it all the way to the promised land
in the finals and we'll see if this is
his year but to start things off his
2019 SEC campaign has to go through
vadas love our Timmy event as we look at
this young man
pretty impressive Robert his stat sheet
yeah and it seems actually like a bad
opponent for Agra shook if you have if
he's traumatized by his recent speeches
change of history he lost to the young
Yonkers up due to last may be the only
person with better here Eric
Ladislav Artemyev is young Christophe
Duda you know similarly age similar
strength but if you look at those
ratings across the board for our temmie
of 2757 classical he has really just
improved greatly as a player he won in
Gibraltar he won the European individual
title he's a member of the Russian
national team and you see his ratings in
rapid and blitz well he's great across
the board and his chest calm Blitzen
bullet are very in line with Alexander
griffix as we now bring up the player
card therefore Sasha we see that those
guys are separated not by much if we
jump all the way down to the second from
the last item just calm ratings are
within the 30 points on both sides and
obviously we know that Alexander
grishnack is also a former world blitz
champion so he's played with the best of
them and if we look at our odds
calculations
Grichuk has relatively
middle-of-the-pack decent chances this
year as far as our prediction sheet goes
any anything jump out to you about these
two guys in the first round vladislav
our team event Sasha crook
you know our team years it's really hard
to kind of pin him down as a fan of his
because he's so young his experience
playing the best players in the world
not too many games there right and on
the other hand gosh he's been one of the
best players in the world for so many
years now former a world number two was
over 2800 as you said former world blitz
champion so he's extremely well known
and that he's extremely ready I think
the games are about to begin these guys
have actually been online for some time
and so we expect their match to get
underway the parousia Aronian match if
you somehow missed it was quite the
thriller Levon Aronian
moves on to the quarterfinals in the
speeches championship by one game he
staved off a massive comeback from the
young man from Iran but now it is time
for Russia to have the spotlight as far
as chess calms viewers are concerned
we've got the Siberian elephant I think
that's what it stands for yes versus
Alexandra crook who I don't know if he
likes elephants but you know there's
maybe you know some association there
how could you now like elephant they're
pretty likable right if you were in the
call audio before our show in live you
would
had the pleasure of hearing Alexandra
Grichuk and their kid his kids right
before they are way past their bedtime
we now I'm gonna talk to Sasha
afterwards about his kids curfew I mean
pretty late in Russia you know he looks
really alert right now yeah he does this
goatee situation is yeah he's growing
these guys fun fact these two guys
actually requested to play the later of
the two matches in this doubleheader so
if you're wondering will there be
fatigue they're pretty used to this time
Vladislav obviously plays in a lot of
title Tuesday's you know as this
Alexander Grisham this isn't far off
from the time period that Alexander I
think feels most alert somewhere around
1:00 2:00 a.m. is where he's hitting his
prime in Moscow by you know what I'm
saying so what do we got here five
minutes yes is underway we have an
isolated Queen pond that's the first
thing to note is Black has his pawn on
d5 that cannot be protected by another
pawn that's what I said green pond looks
like and White has done a good job of
blockading the pond that's what you want
to do eat you don't wanna let that pawn
to push and trade off and and the good
thing about having a nicely pawn is
there you get open files on the adjacent
ones see file and efile we're gonna go
to e8 take make use of the semi open
file a rockin eventually go to c8 to try
to use that file but the C file is so
closed that I wouldn't really focus my
attention there for the time being and
yet you point this out the two matches
ago I'm saying naka Morgan's Dobrev
these sacrifices in the e3 and F two
squares you always have to watch out for
this right Knight coming in to 84 poking
at f2 with the rook also having an eye
in the Queen and Bishop battery already
in full force this is just pretty
typical tactics that can occur in one
way it might have happened if we back up
the analysis board make a useless move
for white would be something like this
if the rook has to leave this Square and
F 2 becomes even more vulnerable now you
really start to look at this being a
pressure point that black can take
advantage of so black plays the move
Knight sorry white plays the move Knight
d2 trying to simplify and get that night
out of his house wave that Dikembe
Mutombo matumbo finger not in my house
and look at how these two guys avatar
pictures we got this up you're an
elephant Alexandra sure one of them is
real close the other one that's not
quite a selfie that's someone else see
someone else took that picture beside
Vladislav right that is a someone else
he for sure
you're off fixture yeah but right now I
think they're sort of feeling each other
out in terms of you know what Styles
they're going to use and there should be
six a good move putting pressure on d4
but I kind of like the way this is going
for grrah shook yeah I'm gonna meet you
the trade is a good sign right you can
take with the bishop and maybe you're
punching d4 through and opening that
diagonal yeah and this III square now is
really vulnerable right there are
definitely gonna be tactics that you
always do in look out for on that square
and if you are Artemia if you have to
like your clock management you're up a
minute so far but crook is used to that
even in classical games he'll be down
it's like three minutes left I didn't
see that coming
yeah that was a nice tactic to get the
transition this is takes f6 here
oh wait that wasn't oversight there's no
way 94 was allowed if we're back this
thing up everyone we we kind of liked
the exchange but Knight takes c6 opening
the Queen to d6 here that was the that
was the main point right I like black
initially because I'm just fantasizing
about d4 and the light squares right
nice before is a great tactic nicephore
the pawn was pinned to the Queen white
wins the bishop pair and then
immediately parts with it to double and
destroy blacks King side this looks like
a good start for the young Russian and
wears wear skirts are gonna put the king
he's thinking a lot here because maybe
he wants what g5 instead I think you
kind of have to go Brooke G folks King
h8 or King outfit okay if they lose the
pawn immediately you can take on h7 and
King h8 I lost Queen h4 hitting f6 and
HTM at the same time so you might want
to king of 8 to 7 run to the center it
doesn't look very good
honestly tough spots white might even
just grab the pawn and say thank you
yeah right thank you come again um you
know if Rick g5 can hold every on to
everything then to certainly move that
deserves serious attention because rook
g5 hits the Queen and if you go Queen h4
well actually how am I going to protect
the pawn anyway queen of 4 or Queen h4
creature how do I protect HIV I thought
I could play rook g7 per second forgot
that f6 was falling so here Grichuk
taking his time but probably because he
doesn't quite know what to do is the
king puts on his running shoes he's
gonna attempt to escape to the center
but looking pretty good Oh Jim you have
to start things off here the one thing
that's good in prevent quotes relatively
good
for Grichuk is there's no immediate
knockout blow and this Bishop on c6 as
you point out is very very strong at
some point d4 and maybe now is a move
that you have to consider especially
with the pin here yeah yep and this
Bishop on h7 they'll go over treat at
some point on the black king you know
from East 7th and if we can run all the
way to b8 that's a much safer King
that's quite the journey Frodo but if
you can make it there you know you can
make it there you can make it anywhere
yo there you go
we're not talking about the Big Apple
here I love a Big Apple Big Apple that
we're gonna get some food later don't
you worry I'll feed you I'll feed you
big guy we got a lot of chess ahead you
keep focused but anyway we've we've had
our second speech Chess Championship
match officially get underway here a
huge thank you to still 13,000 of you
that are with us if you happen to be
watching this at the front page of
twitch or on any one of chest coms and
beds go all the way to our home page
click the follow button this is where
the biggest events happen the biggest
prizes in chess the most exciting events
and the most relevant daily question
stand just been cued by our producer
that we actually have a new one for the
second match of the day what has been
your favorite moment of the first round
of the speech chess championship there's
been a plentiful and whoa I can't wait
let's see what social media brings us
we've we've asked questions about
underdogs we've asked questions about
over the board chest punishment not the
medieval kind but this is a pretty
simple one you've been watching this is
our last first-round matchup of the year
after this we will have the entire
quarterfinals bracket filled so let us
know your favorite moment use the
hashtag speech yes for this one I think
you got to share it on hashtag speech s
on Twitter in order to be relevant
dendup we're giving away a diamond
membership for this one because it's the
second match of the day and I'm feeling
frisky and I like one of the answers in
the chat
ding changing shirts which never
actually happened apparently this camera
changed yeah yeah well I wasn't I wasn't
doing the commentary with you but I
don't ever hearing about it it was crazy
like suddenly the lighting of the camera
changed and we were all convinced he
changed shirts and anyway that was
something all right well Artemyev is
showing a little something-something
here well she's an old dog some new
tricks he's about to be crushed I can
game what you think so I mean there's
some luggage 5 stuff I mean it's not
like come on you're right solid Hey
me bones do I got how many bones you got
you got an extra mile I got an extra one
but you don't really have anything
because you're not playing okay hey the
we the Royal we
okay we were inverted that Queen c8
moves oh oh oh that's a square like King
G aged one of those twos King G 2 stops
it yeah the problem is you can't
actually dislodge the screen from d4 I
like that move though there's gonna be
some Bishop g4 action bishop a check
first perhaps and yeah work see one's
nice though trying to keep that coming
off the die in the tempo have access to
this square if the Queen ventures too
far okay maybe the queen of five hits F
to push one b1 all right you're not
holding anything not hold anything back
now damn ephors possible if you want to
simplify it not because you're winning
right you trade on d7 but getting the
Queen's off the board you're much better
in that game right but before there
might be some queen g4 coming in there
with sacrifice on h4 there's a bit more
Queens you for you're actually pinning
my pond
yeah that's irritating in fact so I
won't it's probably good maybe no I
don't think so
I think you were right I mean rookie
I'll show a rook h4 would was a real
threat because if you do some random
move rook age four you can't take it
cause it's made on g2 so I think I think
that's a real issue and so much so that
our team even plays out for I just don't
want to look at this for white anymore I
don't know I'm just I'm not really
buying griffix position it's all about a
rucksack which just that's not a title
of anyone's autobiography all about the
rook sack but good thing you know his
positions now for sale you didn't buy
anything I mean just queen g4 s common
book takes h4 maybe I put the real
country one and say no to everything
forevermore
right how's that for being a party
pooper that's a party pooper where's my
cop reference during chess show that
nobody saw Oh f5 what what do you take
that pawn rook f1 yeah why did he sack
get he wants f6 clearly but then I'm
Brooke h8 to h6 it protects everything
was not good okay six yeah oh wait a
second then then taken us five queen g4
check uh okay yeah I was gonna say g4
but h4 Falls would check but yeah I have
rook h6 you take and then Queen g4 game
over yeah so maybe it works out and I
should not be critical Queen takes f6
comes now then you gobble back on
network h6 he's still fighting here he's
fighting he's but he's got 20 seconds to
a minute he's had way worse in classical
chess before why are we arguing is it
just been a long day or something why
don't we just get a 1 we all agree
griffix worse he's gonna lose the game
I didn't say well that's that's why
we're arguing I guess cuz I'm right and
you're wrong oh look at that move Queen
takes f7 h5 falls with check and you can
resign I don't go I don't want to say I
told you so so I'm not going to like
what my wife says when she's like I
don't want to point out that I told you
this what did you just do right she does
that all the time I don't want to point
out that I told you that a while ago I'm
not getting involved in your marriage
yeah you already there I'm already
babysitting yeah so Robert was in the
house there the day when the new laundry
machine was delivered and they they
thought Robert was on his husband yeah
it's pretty fun the guy was like not
gonna Rob my hand yeah the house wasn't
like what are you already warned isn't
like that and pretty fun
I don't think Shauna minded anyway but
that's another story
yeah don't share too much about your
home life Dan that's actually what my
therapist advices that's that wasn't my
nickname all right night coming around
to g3 we have a French this will be the
first of many games where we criticize
blacks position because the French is a
bad structure yeah but it's Carrick on
so it's a glorified French that's true
Bishop is outside the pawn chain word
homie 93 broke free from the chains what
you saying it broke free from the chains
one day I woke up and tell me was one of
my favorite people on Twitter I don't
know how it happened nobody does it's
just you're secretly a peaky blinders
no it's just anyway knight c6 here comes
Knight age 5 there's a couple moments
where they've like moved in night out
and retreated as far accidental and
alright right now what is what I can do
h4 h5 is one thing to consider but it's
problem is the night and g6 covers it
ooh f6 going for the break actually it's
getting better than East six is a
problem yeah I've seen worse problems
before Bishop to g6 is also possible and
just take oh but if I take that cunning
with the pawn you're gonna sack the
exchange I would love to think about
let's show at Bishop b3 takes takes
shake-and-bake on f3 and then you take
with tempo this is nuts
yeah the position is still crazy right
like I don't even know if this is
possible but I'm just gonna continue to
calculate an IG six retreat oh no that's
right nuts
I have Queen d3 and anyway yeah it looks
like black is kind of holding her ship
taking his time decides to part ways
with the e pawn instead he got a lot
closer to the camera
he did well oh my god I haven't looked
in a while I just looked over like huge
Sasha for those of you who don't know
and I've been giving criticism don't
call the players by a nickname when
Alexander is on screen Sasha a very
common nickname in Russia for Alexander
and I'm sorry if that confuses you wait
who told you not to say Sasha somebody I
think you're saying Sasha told you calm
Sasha no no he's fine okay because I
don't have to call you Danny I call you
Daniel if you you know whatever you want
all right but I actually do like the
transition because the open e file keeps
the e6 pawn week and positionally this
is a common thing that you have to watch
out for right because whenever f6 is
played in these French pawn structures I
know as a Carroll Khan but whenever the
French pawn structure changes the e6
pawn will become the biggest weakness on
the board yeah and so that's basically
what happened here and white is gonna do
everything you can to keep an eye on
this e5 square so that the e6 pawn stays
weak and that's why the 94 is nice it
kind of blockades the rook anyone that
just went back to f1 yeah the card if -
exactly and this is what rook is doing a
great job of
he's now saying at the e5 square not
only do you have his weakness on e6 and
we talked about with the isolated pawn
you want to block hate it when there's a
backward pawn it's often nice to make
sure it's stopped in his tracks and can
push forward so that eventually you can
put pressure on it yeah so a lot of the
rest of the tension of this game is
going to center around the e5 square and
then nice jumping right there I think
you can't stop me from well that's
actually a very good move I think yeah
keep it we want c5 right you want c5 and
you're saying well what's your pitch 25
really doing it's not actually what
you're right there precisely two pieces
can't occupy the same score in chess
I've tried and now reread that knife
from f3 since you protected the pawn f2
so you can move the night away play f3
or f4 get the Bishop to g4 at some
moment to attack that e6 pawn yeah I
like it
and he might even be a g3 here to put
the knight on h4 not out of the question
I guess the bishop came to g6 the
potentially go to h5 yeah but the thing
is if those light score bishops are
traded who does it really favor I mean
it's it's still you're still dealing
with the weak e6 pawn still dealing with
potentially weak light squares over here
on the Kings side so again this is a
positional grind here for gray shirt
right yeah honestly any trade will still
favor white because this pawn to e6 will
kind of forever be there fun fact is you
look at these two guys they're actually
playing from two a joist adjacent rooms
in a hostel that's kind of look like
that looks pretty much like they're
playing from the same place not just
kidding they're actually just facing
each other and they're standing well at
some point the players should do that to
us
like twist ending they were in the same
room surprise us all right the tickle
goes back and forth
meaning the night goes back and forth
from d2 to f3
yeah I like your suggestion of g3 yeah I
think g3 King G - 9 th for push your F
pawn at some point I think it's the way
forward because I what our tentative
doing is very smart with Bishop c7 yeah
as soon as the knight leaves put Bishop
c7 to attack the e5 square and that's
why GU shuck went right back to f3 and
he's trying to take a think of how to
solve a cube bird in the chest TV chat
says as compared to a normal French
defense black has saved
bunch of Tempe by not having to maneuver
the bishop around here it's kind of true
right I think that the fact that black
has the fully developed situation is why
white has no control over the u.s. look
at that he's finally traded on e he
ended the staredown trade on c7 he
blinked as they say he blinked first I
think he just won the staring contest
well not over yet maybe I sacked the
exchange in play you 500 it's just 95 s
coming here have 70 f3 then I don't have
to move in finally e6 will be weak yep
also there might be a way to win a pawn
right now after f3 was your night going
I know everything that's a positional
move that's high class that's high class
you know he wanted to do if she was
guarding b6 so that when you take
there's no clean b6 targeting the pollen
you know that's interesting actually
that's that's I just learned something
that's high-level prophylaxis future
defensive ideas and actually if you ever
got a six for black up sorry black if
black was a six then I'll go f3 and 0.9
and c5 is white and now you have a new
outpost square another reason why the
pawn on e5 is strong yep yeah
high-quality chess right now the old
guard trying to teach the new guard new
tricks and I'm gonna try not to make
that same reference all day but we do
have one player from Russia who's been
doing this thing of high-level chess for
a very long time at Alexander grishnack
and we have Vladislav Artemyev one of
the rising stars in in the Russian chess
game so which is very close to the
American rap game fun fact Russian chess
game mmm
rising stars f3 when the knight moves we
will see the e6 pawn under fire whoa
cuz rook have to have a queen c1 check
oh wow
Queen c1 sack for mate shake well that's
actually oh oh we played aggressive
Queen e1 he is Queen e1 oh wow what
works oh my god gritty one whatever now
he's in trouble
just rook has beat you just fall yeah
then Brooke c2 comes in Wow Timmy of his
a stone-cold killer look at him over
there why New York weenie one
instead of back to 20 what was better he
says I missed it you saw his reaction he
didn't see it coming
he's yeah wait is that night trapped
like Queen Cedarbrook f2c won this game
is taking a ridiculous turn here yeah
but can't you take no Queen six check Oh
duh Oh suddenly it's not their tibia
blood gonna be laughing all day he
tricked him he tricked him boy no he
blundered exactly blundered into success
Wow if only that worked for me if you're
just joining us fYI this is our second
speech Chess Championship match of the
day the doubleheader action is real we
still have 13 thousand W Levon Aronian
barely got by only resolution our first
match of the day but we're having a
great time we're a little tired but
we're doing it for you and we got a lot
more chess ahead and it's gonna be a lot
of fun so thanks for being here and
Knight to e5 yeah sure he's gonna have
to even the score here now we predicted
Aronian would win the first match we
thought he was the favorite yep it was a
lot closer than we thought I think we
got the party started the right way you
and I have been really back and forth
about who the favorite is here I have no
idea who's gonna win this match well
tell him who you said you know you
thought would be the slight favorite
Alexander Chris Rock yeah and I said
Vladislav Artemia right so that tells
you how close we are here I said why
can't we get along sometimes we gotta
just the experience factor I look at
grishnack not just world blitz not just
being the older the older more
experienced chess player but also the
SEC experience yep again I think the
increment always plays dividends in
their first SEC match all the rest it
just talked about that right yep but as
you said you feel our chimney of is just
he's a rising rapid blitz tore this
guy's a stud and I just listen to what
gosh Rick says yeah my opponent is a
very good player I am definitely not a
favorite well okay
listen to Sasha and he as I've said many
times now Sasha called Artemia of the
Russian Chuck Norris yeah so how can I
not approve which I don't understand the
reference I mean he's just saying that
you know with Chuck all things are
possible
you shall giveth and taketh away
when Chuck does a push-up he doesn't go
up the world goes down yeah I mean I'm
gonna choke yeah keep going this game is
an extra piece for white though yeah the
extra night is strong it's very strong
I'm the best square okay but the
second-ranked makes it a little tricky
and as we look at time combined with a
weak King right yeah Brooke f2 is a good
way to help that King out yeah so it's a
night for just one pawn you could take a
five and many of these variations but
just not gonna be enough they attack I'm
the black King well will happen in a few
moves so I give like Queen c2 I was then
hit they're working at five throne Queen
c8 but he's just gonna rook g1 Queen g3
and gone for g7 straight forward and
without the second rank being an issue
anymore should be pretty pretty smooth
sailing here although again he's just
he's not playing fast enough for for the
nerves to go away now the brook out for
what an irritating move it's not really
good move you're absolutely right but I
gotta read this by antoine b0 wrong
Chuck Norris is the American flat our
time which is exactly the kind of joke
Chuck Norris would be proud of so very
true absolutely fiddler on increments in
the chess TV chat says were the best to
chess commentators and chess has never
been so entertaining
who says I got to say that because we
know we have a lot more haters here than
lover so I gotta give got to give a
shout-out to some good comments there
Thank You Spindler appreciate it not
Peters me that's why I got their
movements I don't know what happens when
speeders on increments the difference
between supplements and increment right
I ate six Jags it's legal here comes
nice yeah very nice it's a fork of both
f6 and the Jeep on being pinned rookie
six tonight back to e5 so now Sasha for
a five here he goes yeah this is the
right idea there Olivia
somehow this became quite the scramble
which is a recipe for disaster when you
were up a piece for 30 moves here here
comes Queen six h6
there we go better now Queen sees h6
next Jim you've let's the clock run out
takes a deep breath just so you know he
is breeding and
he sits almost as far back from his
webcam as the someone else he that is
his avatar picture has him pretty far
back go to SIB elephant and you'll see
that someone else he I'm talking about
someone else he so funny
and look we've off-beat openings yeah I
love it little veresov you know what
they say about the veresov I do not know
what to say where they say this is the
second speeches chambers you imagine the
day you getting that stretch and I heard
that crap it didn't sound good yeah
keeping these old hips loose but we're
pretty excited to be let's remind you
who's playing today let's bring up our
player profile cards they are both from
Russia who will you meet first
it's Vladislav artemiev he is the number
3 player in Russia actually a rising
star as we've said and a lot of people's
darkhorse picked to maybe be the young
Christopher Duda of this year's SCC
right kind of the young player to join
the fold and get a lot farther than we
thought but then there's Alexander
Grisham the guy who's sitting across
from him and there's a whole bunch of
gifted subs on behalf of our stream to
yours those are from our chess channel
here thank you for being here thank you
for watching the hype is real and we're
pretty pumped about the day Alexander
grishnack has played in many SCC's he's
a former world blitz champion and he
just won to level the match so thank you
for being here the speech his
championship the most elite event in
online chess eSports and hit the follow
button before you go anywhere else
tonight's ACH two possible probable hmm
such a weird move to play but it is upon
this hanging it's a chess960 move right
it's it's super greedy well what's my
middle name Guillermo close Gary no
greedy Jorge getting closer I actually
have no idea what you're Bill Davis my
that hurts a lot how am I supposed to
know your middle name your name's Lee
alright ninety seven plays the safe move
to try to make sure that
he has opportunities to castle before
getting too greedy on this pawn on h2
still under under being being spied
there I kind of like capturing that pawn
h2 it would have been interesting right
let's analyze it back this thing up and
why didn't he take it as a question I
wish I had an easy answer the bish one
of five does seem a bit trapped but
thing is you're the queen and the
bischmann f1 are under attack so well if
I take it let's say and I go for and now
Queen takes do you want right you're
getting a ton of pieces here I don't
exchange and I'm gonna get it some pawns
some like this its Queen h2 and I'm not
gonna trap her Queen anyway hmm I
literally have no idea it would have
been an interesting pawn to grab it's
just not a very Orthodox position and
Robert mentioned earlier the very self
opening jokes aside we'll show you it
right here which is defined as this move
Knight to c3 I'll move to and then
developing the bishop this is not the
traditional game you have whenever you
have a queen pawn game meaning the
Queen's pawns are leading the way in the
center very often you have the pieces
going behind the pawns so this is kind
of a really aggressive offbeat approach
and leads to positions look at those
pieces moving twice before your castle
that's also breaking an opening
principle and we get a weird position
where maybe maybe indeed there was a
chance I don't know right why not take
it it's a great question
yeah would have been interesting okay
well if we get a repeat of this the
match is young it's only one one you can
see the scoreboard so if the varus off
becomes a weapon that our Jimmy plays
will that be something he prepared we
asked the players all these types of
questions in the post match interviews
who knows in a big problem with the
veresov in addition to what you're
saying with moving piece twice and just
you how did this often is this policy to
behind the night yeah right you don't
really like having your palm on tonight
because you're not actually attacking
the center this pawn on d5 is very well
defended but if you can imagine that
pawn as you're putting out c4 you're
actually putting pressure on the center
so right G takes f five here black is
happy to take it look at the e4 square
one name pop a pony right on there it's
a nice square that's a nice and another
go to b6 and c4 yeah this is uh how you
handle the veresov as far as blacks
approach
I mean legit you can look at this game
if you're wondering about a system
against it just very straightforward
this line with with g6 I'll move three
very common so nothing fancy in this
game I wonder if this will be an opening
our Jim you have goes back to will see
[Music]
the night comes to b6 as you said Knight
c4 followed by queen bee four could be a
real b2 problem and the only way to
really prevent the knife from getting in
c4 slim b3 but with dark squares yeah
then you got a lot of them dark squares
something like b3 queen a3 check and we
rush the a pawn for the attack against
the king that looks good there are
potential Knight sacrifices anyway we're
gonna see we're gonna see if that's a
thing so he might save the check you
might say that your kings are really
gonna go to be two because there will be
some night c4 sacrifices in the air or
Queen before fall by 94 94 yeah you may
have to go for something like this no
cuz you don't really want to take care
whoa
King b1 he's just doesn't care about the
pressure we're getting scared
we got Queen before here clean before
followed by Knight c4 or Knight a for
mmm-hmm he's gonna take with the Oh you
can play with the DL because of the d5
square opening up yep the natural thing
to do everyone I was I was about to
suggest the F pawn to undal the F pawns
and usually you want to take toward the
center not away from it but in this case
you're freeing a very vital square for
the knight and that may lead to more
attacking chances so do you play for a
cheapo here with Queen b5 Queen B 5 and
you're threatening Queen takes you to
followed by Knight c3 form town I'll
show the cheapo because people love
tactics as much as they say like we
don't want to watch bad things on TV yet
you keep watching the Kardashians
there's a train wreck for you that's how
you win a queen I thought there was
appropriate it was appropriate so funny
alright the Queen establishes herself on
c3 the fact that white can't play rook
d3 yep that's huge because here comes a5
a4 a3
I'll go fool the car knock more a 5 a 4
a 3 get Castle can't be too mated early
5 YH 5 no idea like he's trying to stop
G for yes and so he can Castle kingside
but now I can't Castle kingside
and we're in a situation where Queen B 5
check is now on the docket you have to
watch out for the C 2 square yeah the
Queen runs to Farsi to Falls okay thanks
dirty Darrell Lea 7
put the King on d7 there's Queen B 5
juggling Quincy no no the King g6 and
run to f6 oh my gosh
it's gotta be kidding me let's look at
it hey we saw mommy job do didn't do it
but if Queen b5 King e6 Queen d5 king of
6 the team just runs to safety you know
okay that would have been nuts rook d5
instead maybe threatens things like
clean b5 so Chris chick says it will no
longer be check I block that diagonal
sir
and now rook h6 he's just going for the
D pawn is that opponents 1 or 2 far
right is the stray calf scenario but
it's on the D file so you got to give a
new name that was an all dogs go to
heaven D for dog you summers you got to
read between the lines of my pop-culture
references ok just aren't really lines
they're more like scribbles all right
rook a 6 and a d6 pawn ya know it really
has gone too far the one thing is if
it's all traded and H falls whenever we
get into Queen and pawn endings there's
always chances for draws even if you're
down upon because this King will be open
maybe White has some perpetual checks
coming right yep but if the problems of
your Queen goes away from the e2 square
the f2 pawn is gonna be vulnerable
so that's why when h4 so when he takes
h5 the h1 is closer to promoting square
but at this very forest
calculation here with rook takes d6 oh
you know he might do after takes on d6
go queen takes h5 first perhaps and then
if you trade its check yeah and no way
the f2 pawn is gonna be lost
whines okay we're gonna find out I think
he's gonna go for what you said yep
and he's also threatening f7 and f5 see
you missed it looking for face he
totally missed manage five first time to
wake up Sasha it's like can you put
Queen d4 or that actually my end and of
losing pawn and game because the H fun
yeah
this is one of those really dangerous
transitions where that protected
password gives white a lot of power
although if you push it to h5
that's when tree Queen traits become
good for black yeah because the talent
wants to be picked off yeah we're just
missing things so far you know he's
making it very clear by his his
reactions but he's just that was like a
charge are being never go full charge
our reference the one character we all
wish we could head back okay but let's
invite everybody of what a passed pawn
is since we got about fourteen thousand
people here the basic definition of one
of the most common endgame advantages
and chess is that when you have a pond
and there's nobody in front of it that
is called a passed pawn because you have
the potential to become a queen or
something else when you reach the edge
of the board so big difference in the
position as White's advantage of this
protected passer that is always starting
to run okay but black wants to take and
get a passer of his own
unfortunately that probably allows a
perpetual and I think as fun as this
game has been we're about to see our
first draw of the match right here can
the king run away somehow ooh
king of seven wait so if he goes f7 I
don't see it I wasn't queen e7 check
when tha okay I'll get the right on cue
we've got our perpetual check image to
remind you of this word we've been
saying a few times called a perp the
appropriate kind the appropriate type of
perp in a chess game that you've been
losing is to go for a draw
Oh back on camera take a breath you need
it and you know who doesn't like perps
the chest police the chest police oh
dude that was sick
that's my producer art let's go to
studio C shout out for those of you that
are just tuning in to the chest world
for the first time you didn't know the
studio is real
lots of chess Roberts say hi I'm saying
hi no wave hi to the camera
thank you what's up Jaron we got Jaron
is carrying over there are in Hawaii
pulling the strings and we got a lot of
action here today we're already about
five plus hours in of chess coverage and
we got a lot more to come thanks for
being here
yeah and you just want full dad mode I
mean Robert say hi what do you say to
guests
kiss your mother whatever the dad say
like I think you better hug your mother
when she comes over for Thanksgiving
you'll always be her little boy Robert
your kids aren't old enough for you to
say that they live at home okay what do
we got here some sharp play coming yeah
hopefully let's back this thing up take
a look at how we got here the analysis
tells us that we have a Sicilian con
defense with a six plate early a six
transposes the consus iliyan is defined
by these ene six pawns developing early
keeping the dark square Bishop open as
well as sometimes some really aggressive
Queen side developments like Queen c7
and b5 so that's what black is trying to
do and that's pretty much what black
does in this game eventually plays b5
and we have an all-out Sicilian kind of
attack right blacks got Queen side space
white is preparing for a mating attack
on the Kings side for cage three look at
that
Brooke lift look at that rook lifts
guarding the third-ranked
never asked for shook if human lifts bro
yes that rook is up there you're even
rook lift bro the the Brooke here
actually has multi purposes that's
highlighted guarding the bishop on d3
also preparing just to be off of the
diagonal
tactics right that Bishop is spying it
and that allows you to be a little more
flexible with f5 with E 5 all those sort
of things where the rook can eventually
come to the center so there you go each
T fp0 says rook h3 is such a crucial
move I never know what that means
but sounds like a compliment though so
let's just take it but it is a very
interesting idea because you said it
gets off the diagonal and you never know
where that rook might want to go or if
once you Castle queenside the a1 rook
might end up on the H file if you need
to double up there so it could be
interesting to see how quick you know
Ford here h5 g6 is an obvious idea that
just says look at that pawn f7 you
really wanted to stay there to protect
East six but if I can there it is the
start of that plan are you going to look
play h6 and say look at your Bishop on
f8 I'm gonna take over the dark squares
and your bishops gonna have to sit and
not be so pretty one of the things that
black has sort of in his back pocket in
these positions is that if he hasn't
done too much damage on the Queen side
he can always castle along and sort of
get out of Dodge run away from White's
coming pollen storm he 5 is a nice move
a common move in these Knight offs
because you sort of stick it to the pawn
on e4 so that it's forever forever there
which blocks the bishop and maybe gives
you a long-term target the problem is
exactly what we're seeing right opens up
the f5 Square and even the d5 square and
another issue is usually when you play
e5 you want a knight to replace the pawn
on e5 right you want that 9075 and that
you just clogged the square but you're
not some b6 which means there might be
some tactics around the move white move
e5 you ever take on f4 so that's why you
just Castle queenside and you don't
really see players Castle queenside too
often in Sicilians nobody ni like what I
was foreshadowing that that might happen
yeah and I like the transition with E 5
and castles because as a knight or flare
myself who's lost many of the I mean one
many of these positions is black I can
say that no jokes aside this is this
isn't bad because if I'm thinking about
this how would I take advantage of the
rook look at White's King White's still
in the center here yeah right
I mean well before might be an option
for white right you're always the
conservative seriously that's a danger
danger Will Robinson
or in this case Knight on c5 but the
thing is the White King on E one you
played before you're not going
- the Queen says oh he goes Castle
queenside makes sense doesn't commit to
any kind of unnecessary pawn moves yeah
to early and yeah so interesting
both sides have castled long a lot of
people still talking about the thriller
that you may have just missed if you're
happen to just be tuning into our chess
channel for the first time hit the
follow button and you would have been
here for Levon Aronian number one in
Armenia vs. Olly Reza firoozeh number
one in Iran Aronian barely escaped by
the youngster to move on to the
quarterfinals so it was it was quite the
match yeah that was as thrilling as they
come we've had young christophe Duda
we've mentioned his name many times
he'll be telling a car now comeback kid
is the nickname he's earning at least in
the SCC I thought it was Rick Astley but
that's because the rick roll anyway in
this particular position look he's
almost like black castle kingston on the
queenside because when you Castle
kingside your king goes one Square from
the flank file and here that's happened
for black and look at the rook on c8
it's aiming down the CFL but the bishop
on d3 then let's see the recombination
do well to prevent any sort of huge us
at least for now but I don't know I mean
one thing I like about Sasha's a game
here as compared to the first three he's
up on the clock
yeah he normally gets himself under time
pressure as we know but so he clearly
feels like he has a sense of what to do
here but but I kind of like the way our
Jimmy has played this one Bishop takes
b5 ideas at the right moment
yeah look out for thank you for the bits
they're super appreciate that glad you
like the dance moves if it'll bring more
bits all dance moves all night long baby
I'll throw you uh I'll throw you some
floss if you're into it I got the
sprinkler oh you have never seen my
Carlton you had never seen nothing till
you see my Carlton all right Brook g8
threatens g6 yeah
also over protects the G pawn in case
this Bishop needs to do something but
you just asked a question is there a
sack on b5 at some point I think so
f4 wait yeah yeah I mean he gave up the
pawn for the moment to win it back
opening up many files in the process
now you can't protect that 400 but that
Bishop trying to come in g7 may guess
that long diagonal I think gage 6 will
be played because of that but then G 5
is a permanent weakness along with the
pollen on H 6 again this just I don't
know and I'm normally biased to whiten
these positions you know that we've had
a lot of things together some of it
chess and and I like black here because
you want to where you can do with your
pieces though
how you gonna continue this game I'm
asking the tough chess questions because
you want this night to jump immediately
from c5 to e5 he plays Bishop e7 I was
gonna say put a rock on he ate first but
I liked f6 you're you're getting rid of
the cheap own as a target but you're
getting your Bishop to the diagonal your
cue tonight when you plate this that's
why I wanted rookie a first over protect
now you know I guess where you settling
are you selling on d8 good there also
bishop things b5 now and now b5 is on
the agenda for sure oh that's not a fun
move to play look at that move the
battery is real backup the night maybe
even play d4 to really take away every
square of that pony I like I like before
he's six makes first six also looks good
ready to take yeah Justin the black is
moving backwards and white is clearly
getting initiative here pawn d6 a
permanent weakness the 97 stuck there
not easy to protect the pawn d6 cuz your
bishops on d8 where a rook would be
better placed there yeah that's no fun
look at that patient move threatening
Brooke takes d6 everyone because when
the knight takes Bishop takes will win
the Queen that's a pin to the king so
you're saying you know that yeah we know
tell me I'm looking for that mate for
you
not everyone has the chemistry that a
bishop does with a queen in creating an
absolute pin if you didn't know what
that was read that informational card
above you there hope you appreciate our
chest tips
yeah alright g4 played just trying to
get a diagonal for the bishop yeah and
what one like use take on d6 with the
rook of the bishop with the bishop take
take take with the rook you're
threatening rook takes a six yeah it
just feels like this seems very
vulnerable for black is this yeah I
agree
I might start with a four though like an
initial position a for sometimes edges a
break open I like that also you can do
it cuz the Queen guards see to its full
board awareness he's gone it's all for
the line you talked about when I take
with the Queen on d6 ooh it's also an
option but yeah rook takes definitely
better takes qb7 was my question because
then you have a pin druk to your queen
on HT that was the worry
hmm to make Queen e5 there things I
always have this rook f7 idea if you
ever go push me seven so you're not
gonna be able to just pin in with my
rook
yep got pin and win right back hey
you've been pinning him winning he's
going for the rook up seven minutes like
it should be seven work of seven and
that's you should be seven work of seven
just to show it because if you take I
get your queen with check so you don't
get my lady here it is
h7 is also hanging which you know may
not seem relevant at first but that's an
H pawn that's if we played oh he goes
for the Queen sack allow takes with
check I don't think he's gonna like that
Queen g'wan Queen she won such a key
move hitting G 4 and a 7
look at you calling the shots put the
Queen on her favorite spot you love it
here comes Queen a7 and the g4 pawn can
also just be captured but Queen a7 is
take your first right what is black
gonna do take here uh-huh
that's dynamite check all unipole Ian
call me explosive when I hit that square
now Queen D for hitting g7 a7 hey
grocery iron this is getting better with
what the day is it goes on here this
match gets longer Queen g7 check oh he's
trying to a queen c6 check those keep
movies clean back and forth
Queen d4 back as possible Quincy
forecheck as possible I like it of the
King just said I'm be said I don't know
why I want to be 8
it's intuitive as a human you want your
King on the opposite coast where's the
bishop right right I mean I agree with
you but it's just funny right because we
asked that question and that's
definitely why I just psychologically
didn't want the Queen there how much I
mean black does not have much time left
either but give him credit for the
blockade right the bishop holding both
rooks this is this is actually not an
easy position if this was over the board
with lots of time on the clock black
would black would have some chances here
Queen threes good for 63 first yeah
please c3 I like that move by crusher
bring the Queen and just be patient
because look at the clip c4 here just
work it
here goes mission may 6 next all the
Brooke is running out of square it's
very nice cheers Queenie six now or King
a2 or King C - I like a - cuz I just
don't give the black or get any checks
in the f5 yeah okay good point and that
means when your queen comes back to d4
oh I thought that was even better
hitting both these squares again looked
pretty good
okay Queen D for now second time around
there you're still covering the f2 so
very importantly now just taken out for
ya winning pawns these guys keep at it
they'll almost be as good as us they
keep at it we're gonna get me I guess in
these moves six moves in this time
control check and make it smooth six
games I mean oh I thought he would check
for a queen a six but Bishop e8 was the
thing so okay but plenty of time
Chris Chuck about to take his first lead
of the match if you're just joining us
the younger Russian won the first game
Grichuk leveled the score and after a
draw we have our second victory for
grishnak in the match our first shoutout
to grandmaster to be playing guess the
move over there let's try to get the
guest to move scoreboard going at some
point here we've got a lot of people
playing it diamond members title players
lots of fun go to chess calm directly so
you can play guess the move I'll share a
link to the game in chest comm TV chat
if one of our mods can help us out maybe
share a link and I ruined everything
you've ruined l don everything's gonna
be okay watch this orange nothing
happened crisis averted must be proud of
you you ruined it in the first place
well it just shows you were real human
beings
here that you make mistakes well you
didn't apologize 15,000 people no no I
am sorry I'm sorry that gave our like a
little bit of everything's gonna be okay
Aires gonna be okay and there's the link
and you see the link as well in the
twitch chat you can go there play guess
the move which is actually a really fun
game you try to make the move before the
players do and a lot more prizes a lot
more stuff coming with guests the move
we've got big plans so enjoy it have
some fun while you can danny is a real
boy says he'll Berta he's a real boy
Yeah right not a made up not a made-up
character what do you think whether
these dark squares though I'm a little
worried we've got the real Peters
fiddler by the way in twitch chat and we
are the faith and we've got the fake
Peters feather in chess TVs fiddler on
increments is saying Danny would you
agree with me thats fiddler is the most
polite chess player in the world even
more polite than Robert referring to
himself in the third person because
already claimed to be anyway back to the
chest
it's just awesome Fighting's my
brother's name is Peter so that sounds
like an argument we would have with my
parents more younger who's more polite
is amia Robert shout out just fiddler
we'll see him tomorrow for the Fisher
random World Chess Championship
quarterfinals and shout out to everybody
that's with us thanks for being here
these seven positions worry me because
they have four square yeah it just it's
blocks for the taking you can plant that
Bishop run out for if white goes g5 I
mean it's not that threatening you know
it's gonna matter each five plant the
pony on at four instead and look at her
shirt just trying to go a five a four
and open up the queenside
90 of six look at that just avoiding g5
so it doesn't open up the kingside at
all yeah this is not looking too
Pleasant you can go age five here that
would be how you shut it down shut down
the studio dialogue I agree with Mario
Bros
David Navarre is the most polite I would
have to agree Wesley so gave him the run
for his money in that interview
yesterday yeah but Navarre is is like
the nicest and there's no obvious Lee
was extremely nice to page three is a
super tricky move threatening g6 here
everyone if something like a four occurs
g6 and even if you take with the bishop
bishop takes six undermines the F pawn
and
keeps whites attack alive so he took on
g5 for that reason but but that invites
the night and now I want to take with
the bishop on e6 and and fork this is
black I'm played g6 here I don't really
wanna be like King f8 right I just
invites rook D to G 1 and G 6 looks
hideous as an option I'm so surprised
still that he didn't take with the
knight though that that hitting the
bishop and the threats there okay he
might give up this g7 point actually
yeah from a practical perspective makes
sense a4 let's look at it
a4 rook takes g7 do you just slide the
Queen right away and just ignore
everything over here on the Kings side
yeah you're going for a human attack it
takes me 3 Queen a to check who checks
c4 yeah Bishop 8 look at us completing
each other's I wish we had Sam we'll get
some sandwiches later oh man
hey look at that I got much love from
pool Bertha there see that you're
reading it now
Chris Chuck but you're now you're trying
to say it right I'm just I just wanted
you to acknowledge that I'm Cedric I'm
not saying you said it wrong but fiddler
just just let me have my moment
see and David has no rivals never will
Navarra
nice guy yeah but look at that Bishop on
a fade I think that's a good move
actually guarding g7 so that you can
focus your efforts again over here on
the Queen side and just goes to show
that how is why can I continue the
effort working a second exchange in g7
go for it
that doesn't he's gonna do it he's gonna
call your bluff right here he goes well
I don't think it's my blowing his
position is bad and this is coming from
someone who's had the white side up
positions like this many times right he
started with b3 the Nakamura and what
happened was he got his want B to
but look how bad that Bishop is in the
game composition on that diagonal ya
know it was it was the b3 kind of Hippo
Nakamura but a weird decision for the
old lady to swallow the fly and block
everybody this whole this whole opening
is just one of those things that you
play in Bullitt and blitz when you're
playing online chess and this is why I
favored grishnak in this matchup because
this is a really serious chess this is
like this is like to win an SEC match
you bring your opening preparation bring
your repertoire and and that's just the
truth we've seen it right this
like not even Hikaru you know plays real
openings in these in these events right
I just don't think this is the kind of
opening white is gonna feature and do
well consistently yeah interesting
decision by artemiev because it didn't
feel like you know in the prior games
that he needed to venture out into b3 in
these offbeat openings and right now he
is in a situation where he has a pawn
and a dark square bishop for a rook and
if somehow you can open up the dark
squares then I'll be happy but but he'll
yeah there's a pawn on d4 that's judge
strong protected by another pawn and
Bishop to c1 that diagram is something
useful right queen of four I wonder if
what he's recognizes now that he's up to
exchange Robert he forgets the Queen set
attack is he gonna Castle long and the
trade on the G file right an idea I mean
the thing is the queen of f4 guards f7
so I started thinking it that might be a
sneaky intent Castle long put the other
Brooke on g8 and I get to get more
pieces off the board the prominent
Knight g5 hops in there at some point
and f7 is under attack you
okay maybe not okay he goes for right
away but Bishop c6 I think is the Ben
just take on g6 right that's just seems
less than ideal but okay yeah put the
bishop on g8 so Queen takes h4 is meant
by Knight d2 to f3 and that's a real
compensation but look at us Bishop g8
makes sense I think I look at me look at
you you're the genius thus was Sasha was
Sasha and oh yeah okay I was gonna say
I'm your Robin today you're that you're
the Batman well you're the one in the
Batcave so you kind of have to be Batman
well Robin gets the keys to the Batcave
eventually well then it takes the motor
bike and then yeah yeah almost off the
ledge okay Bishop g8 played I do believe
that this idea of counseling long is a
secret intent potentially that makes
sense it's funny because we've talked
about the rook and eight hits the a to
pawn and there's a lot of pressure there
yep but you're right if you need to
shore up your King Stein and Castle
queenside to make sure that everything
is safe then yeah at some point it can
happen I really like putting a piece on
e5 soon yep right especially if the
knight is traded h4 becomes weak again
maybe not with the rook cuz of g8 but
right the tactics here get
order for white as the pieces are traded
because you're down the exchange and
okay he goes for ninety five would like
it as the position simplifies black
should be just up material Bishop c1 I
like this there's queen of six tempo but
now you can cast along if you want
he's unwinding he's getting that Bishop
out yeah those are nice six ideas so
open the c5 pons hanging that's the
problem you don't want to lose that fun
what's funny is white is kind of like
one coordination away from being okay
like if you could put the Queen on g3 or
something a Knight takes e5 and f4 and
then if Queen takes the discoveries yeah
oh let's look at that Knight takes
Knight takes f4 Queen takes Discovery
Channel population Queen on f4 but
there's maybe Queen f3
you can tell certain move but offering
the Queen trade
I think he's calculating it he's got
extra time so our Tim you have up on the
clock unlike he was in the previous game
wanting to win to level the score here
obviously if you're just joining us we
have a one-point lead for Alexander
Couric and let's talk about the
discovered attack a tactic that occurs
often in chess where one piece moves and
reveals the attack behind it which is
what we were just talking about you can
see a pretty good example of that and
I'm moving to reveal an attack on the
Queen so basic tactics for those tuning
in we appreciate you being here if it
happens to be your first chest show or
if you happen to be like your hundreds
just showing like me it just took you a
long time to learn discovered attacks
that's okay too
no judgments judgment free zone
completely agreed what's he thinking
about now now the time has gone far
enough that you're wondering well you
just put a calm move maybe you're
suggesting that his positions not so
terrible and black to them clear now
nice eighty five is a big threat because
then you follow with f4 and look at the
bischmann g2 and we're gonna eight
staring each other down diagonal nice
and by each other I mean the bishops
tears on the rook yellow can stare back
yeah it's like when someone's looking at
you from across the room and you're like
feeling self-conscious cuz they know you
and you don't know them exactly that
happens you often it's awkward it feels
it feels weird sometimes we've got night
6504 coming actually it's hard to stop
because if you move the night if you
move the night from me five e five
comes anyway yeah and we've got the same
stare down mmm look at I'm sorry 17
seconds 16 seconds counting down for
gurke and what's going on yeah no time
on the clock we might have a scramble to
bring this one to a close
buckle up kids it's gonna be a bumpy
ride
Oh II play c5 to shut down the bishop I
love it
no more tactics okay it's a commitment
right yeah also sacrifice and and the
fact that our team has kept the pressure
that he has and black has struggled so
much with coordination you got to give
him credit right if you could just put a
bishop on g5 I was trying to h5 he's
using an extra pawn yeah and the time
favors artemyev h5 yeah I like you try
85 and then Bishop f5 he might start
with Bishop f5 or if I've also good
right away agree but this move order I
think a little six even six in Brook g7
pot bit oh yeah what a game right now I
mean this is the conversation here is
real Bishop g5 Queen d6 only move Knight
h4 Wow
what a tough position to play black with
only three seconds I take g6 Bishop d7
check looks like a pretty good option
even rook d7 is like weird yeah but I
think you win the black queen right now
96 F g6 Bishop d7 check yeah
takes in d3 I didn't like taking that
pawn that seemed unnecessary and now
he's getting down on time yeah that did
not seem like a good decision early
moment in the match but could be a game
we're talking about later on depending
on the result here so he forcing take it
out a check
whoa that's not good blundering away to
game here night before maybe for a night
before was mate oh my god sick we're
gonna back up and show you night before
was a Queen sacrifice for mate let the
game finish but we're uh we're gonna
show you what just happened there that
was nuts
we're uh we're gonna wait here for the
game to finish and then we'll show you
what happened in that one wow what a
crazy tactic he made and now I mean the
black kings in big danger here they
should be seven whoa and he went
on time Wow big Rick miss a chance to
win that game now we'll bring it up and
show you as soon as this next one gets
underway what we've got here was a weird
tactic we're instead of playing Queen
takes tea to trading Queens black had
night to be for sacrificing the Queen
because of rook takes a to with mate yep
show you again Knight to b4 and rook
takes 8 you made I think Sasha missed it
and may have just cost himself the
chance at a two-game lead in the match
dang maybe should do more puzzle battle
maybe he should do more puzzles I love
so dark show it one more time it was
good it was it was it was kreygasm
worthy or use Hesse chasm if you're a
subscriber that's the really moat for
big chess moments let me show you what
do you think about these lines with this
Queen on d3 I always feel uncomfortable
as white I don't like the square d3 for
my queen the e4 pawn feels vulnerable
but maybe Sasha feels better about it
I've played a lot of these as white you
asked me a real question I mean I think
the problem I have with this is you
always end up wanting to undo it right
it's not a maneuver that you you
continue to build on but okay if you can
if you can get castled before get a rook
to the D file oh and this actually might
be another way to do it as well okay
given a g7 because g2 will be a goner at
the end of that you take on g7 I go
Brooke she ain't take so Sasha thinking
here and you got this Hedgehog structure
right but the bishop can come to b7 the
knight come to d7 you put
rook on c8 Castle kingside super solid
but he goes for it on that note
one of the risks of taking the GT upon
us maybe the rook never finds its way
back home yeah there's always weird
ideas here like
no because of 98
thank you it's a nasty me yeah Queen h3
does the job
so I guess White's Castle in Queens what
is well ahead in development but way
down on the clock we should be doing
kind of his old old tricks here where he
gets gets behind on time and again as
much as he's known as a great blitz
player a world blitz champion a former
but Greg is somebody who consistently
gets himself under time pressure right
he does well there's some kind of second
he's six not in yet not yet but you know
I'm tempted you know what I do with
other people's pieces I've been talking
about it for years I'm sorry I don't
listen you know forgive me
speaking of sacks thought one of the
other ideas is to keep the king of the
center put a rook on c1 and I don't know
this line probably not as good but you
always got to keep an eye on that d5
square right something went wrong here
for progression yeah and II can't go
Bishop f3 either cuz c4 hangs yeah
Bishop of three runs into Queen takes
although there might be five there it's
one of those things you really have to
count eight castles long he's laughing
at the e6 is hanging but not hanging
tactic yeah yeah let's analyze it and
show it if Knight takes Knight takes
takes we have Knight takes c6 at the end
and after captures Queen takes we have a
double attack on the rook and Bishop
Knight f6 there might actually some of
them actually did he not see that Oh
hold the phone take something for my
phone away
exactly exactly Jed exactly
so what's going on here black is
currently up upon white has this light
squared bishop which is gonna be great
look a lot of week light squares for
black here and a lot of week pollens on
light squares - yeah me Bishop g5 ideas
for black just trade off the bishop try
to get the 97 to f6 or c5 art enemy of I
guess still still relatively confident
huh just even up the match score two and
a half all and ogre shook will continue
to get himself in time trouble you have
an hour Kim you've taken a bit of a
think I'm not sure where the tactics
should should go here for black do you
want the dark square Bishop Soph or
maybe try to do something more
aggressive on the Queen side I don't
know I keep wanting to do something
while the King is really weirdly
vulnerable even brought this night on c5
that was definitely not the move I was
expecting I mean either why'd he choose
it that night okay well I think it's cuz
he wants the other the other night to
come to c5 at some point yeah I
definitely understand why he's doing was
doing but I was not expecting any of
this so did I in situ you would love to
scoot it up to c3 or b5 exactly yes are
you the ultimate squares you're going
for are here but yeah this Knight is
oddly out of place right but 93 might
come but still you really want it to be
5 now you know that you've come into a 5
so it's sort of smart by are 10 you have
to play a 5 when the knight can't get to
b5 well he answers our question like we
said he brought the other night back
because he did want c5 for this pony and
I think there's this long-term
positional bind black and get like a 4
hold b3 even efore so he's trying to get
all his pieces on their best squares
they're just trying to live their best
life here comes e4 or you know II four
is the move that you often want to take
back because that's a pawn that totally
right especially if this bishop gets out
that's a pawn that was serving great
purpose here but
but black has space I don't know I keep
liking our Timmy's positions more and
it's not just because like our last
staff showed along with Jung Christophe
Duda they are the highest rated players
in the world under the age of 23 so if
you're wondering how this is a type
match who's the youngster against
Alexander grec they're looking at the
future in Russia I think you're looking
at the present further prove that deep
alright so 93 I like our team's approach
and I know it's ultra aggressive note
the pawn can't be taken because the
brook was hanging it just feels I'm
gonna disagree with you you disagree you
think he over pushed okay I think that
sasha is going to have an attack soon
the white king is much safer if his d3
pawn is lost which it looks like it's
going down shortly I'm just not seeing
what that Bishop on e7 is going to do is
he yelling timber did you really just do
that to me I sure did
Queenie for put the rook on D 1 and D 5
we'll see if you yell timber in a minute
I still like black I'm taking black in
this game okay Ivan you just caught me
off guard with that amazing
reference yeah 94 although as I say I
like black I'm starting to regret it
because those light squares there's like
oh man I think I should put this rook on
d1 card the knight III yeah completing
each other's sentences and it hurts cuz
I just pick black but then I might go to
e4 to stop rook c3 yep there it is okay
so now we're switching sides again now
you like black again you just have to
keep changing your mind I don't know
what's going on with me today it's one
of those days
h7 mmm note that everything is guarded
though right we've got the knight on d4
guarding c2 what's your work doing here
and BD Doug even there are some ideas in
that f2 at some point yeah I kind of
want Bishop a4 so I can meet that f2
with rook c1 mmm check my dad you're
gonna be nice to Brookes e3 for the time
being ah okay yeah that's the good news
that is the good news
rook to b3 give me that b6 pawn he wants
he wants to put his king on the seventh
rank so that the f7 pawn might hang with
check
that's a great point full board
awareness use it it's a lot like the
force in chess if you don't use your
full board awareness do you lose it if
you don't use your full board awareness
you lose it that is correct yep just
checking for confirming it's actually
true because you can develop your
visualization skills we got a video
series on that on chess calm I did it
it's great video series I think go check
it out
so queen h3 back I think is the move
here I kind of wanted f6 swear to God I
was just about to say that just to open
up a more aggressive route for the queen
of return and again the light squares
are where the tactics are gonna happen
ya know it makes sense and the bishop on
a fate looks so silly there yeah and if
you take there's even look back to f3
immediately oh your Queens hanging
besides that right Knight takes move the
Queen
sorry move the Queen Queen a5 turns
Queen takes a five as well in some lines
ya gotta be careful I was at the time
situation favoring Sasha so sexy 7 over
protects mm-hmm the f7 fold so now
what's the follow-up here the good thing
about the rook being on c7 is at some
point Knight b5 might come with the
tempo but rookie 5 is a nice move knight
is pinned now and I'll watch out for
tactics now rook c3 so threat because
the knight spin mm-hmm that's key we're
got d5o bishop before that's no fun
there are two rooks there skewer tailed
oh he goes for it maybe there's
something that black can do is like a
little tricky thing don't worry just
missed it had to be sure for no no no
it's a Bishop d6 I guess just give up
the rook da brush from on e5 hit the f6
pawn hit the diagonal hope that it works
out a lot of wishful thinking you know
Bishop d6 just play it I think you have
to anyway Zack the exchange but I think
I can play Queen d3 if you know white
is slowly they're like crystal
Queen t3 Bishop before gosh that hurts
oh wow queasy taking with
and you're threatening to take here
interesting a five that was the key
thing that didn't work before his the
night was no wait of course just hanging
out yeah with tempo on the Queen that's
not good
what happened here we're about to see
another time scramble to bring us a
result here every one thirty seconds
remain for Alexandra shook eighteen
seconds on the board for our Jimmy of
well that was a huge blunder using a
stack of screen Bishop takes these no
you can't do that
be six is hanging but is it mate Queen
takes f4 Queen Dixon for Queen takes v6
and the King runs and worse the goods he
gets out yep who knew you in some more
twenty four seconds to twelve seconds
this is gonna be a scramble Queen takes
a five is possible just take it that
smart decision cuz D for you pushed up
on too far put the King on a two it's
actually a practically very difficult
position to play for black lots of
checks yep lots of weirdness Queen
before games a tempo oh that's nice I
would say Queen b6 but I like Queen
before it's gonna be four also maybe was
a queen f8 check yeah they're seven
falls to check their now you double your
trying to corral the D pawn and you
won't be in danger of losing in theory
maybe fate I thought rook g3 instead of
rook D three potentially so he goes for
the second time now round as possible
okay if check King d7 Queen a4 check the
attack continues the attack rages on yep
this time scramble it's real you know I
like my eggs Jack wait scramble rook ta
check routier check was just winning
dude go back and play rugby eight time
knows to be a draw gonna be draw
Grichuk has missed two wins two wins in
the match so far if you're just joining
us the last game where grishnack was
black he let slip away in our Tim you've
won Grichuk has has not been as
tactically sharp there on the time
scrambles yeah Wow let's back up on the
analysis board and show you why Brook da
was winning for everyone who may or may
not just be joining us in this position
after king d6 rook to d8 crushing on the
spot if the King goes to the e-file we
win the Queen and if the king goes to
the C file we have
of Brooksie Brooksie one is actually
perfect now because you can't go see -
yeah so Brooks anyone just wins Gregor
shook shook I'm allowed to say to him is
he shook he might be shook that's the
right emphasis on the wrong syllable
he looks pretty you know does not look
shook no I mean but that's been to games
though it's it's now it remains a tied
match but it's obviously you know if ifs
are always whatever my dog was a cat be
a cat right so you know if don't help a
lot of people okay but in the case where
you're looking at some of the strongest
chess players in the world you expect
them to convert on those critical
moments and Grichuk has uh has just not
been as sharp there in the time Scrabble
he has not but right now with the black
pieces his position is very tricky
because his Bishop on c8 is stuck there
for the time being the be seven pounds
under attack the bishop runs you to
better that much much much better than
Bishop one c8 and there's an imbalance
with the bishop on g7 versus a knight
and there's an isolated pawn for white
but it's very easy for it to whites the
defender you know rook to d1 some
moments soon and look at these pawns for
black now BB might even trade itself at
some point the only downside has the
obviously opening the bischmann she said
right yeah and right away not possible
precisely because of that but okay if
you uh those people don't aren't that
bad actually hard to attack they're
doubled and isolated but hard to get and
they do the fact that they are there
means that this rook is open which might
gain black a tempo at some point because
I might put a three when you'd like to
play something else right force you to
play a three in fact seventeen minutes
only remain here in the five minute plus
one second increment portion if that
happens to be your first speed chess
championship let's remind you real quick
of the format we have 90 minutes we're
almost done with that of five minutes as
the foundation and then one second
increment added back onto the clock with
every move after this we're gonna have
an hour of three minutes plus one second
added back for every move and then 30
minutes of bullet we have a bracket of
16 players this is the last matchup of
the first round Robert can you believe
how far we've come how long
and what are they what are they playing
for let's remind them of the prizes real
quick a lot of cash well I would cash
money and we see that in the first round
here the winner gets $1,000 and goes
more importantly goes on to the
quarterfinals and the rest another
thousand dollars gets split by win
percentage every game is important
altering the win percentage and then you
go into the quarterfinals where there's
a lot of money there twelve thousand
total for eight players and the semies
have 12,000 gambled for only four
players and the grand finale 10k on the
line just two players one match lasting
several hours but for the trophy the
grand prize the spot cash plus the chip
yeah not too bad and this is our second
match of the day Levon Aronian barely
got by all the arrests of Perugia
earlier so we're having a lot of fun we
hope you're enjoying the big big chest
day here on chess calm and thanks for
being with us alright so once thought I
said that those meatballs aren't bad
when I was referring to the be pawns go
for some Italian to go anyway be for
played the be pawns are bad optically
right but you need ways to attack them
black would like to put the Bishop on c6
and exchange it so that they can maybe
even done undable to like before you
also just weakened you're a pawn I
didn't like before I was gonna say as
much as you like before us in the
metaphorical you right because the a
pawn is now weak and you can't move that
pawn backward watch out for that but
also instead of before it just felt like
why could have been more aggressive and
perhaps play two moves like Knight to a4
hitting that pawn on d6 yeah and I guess
it'll go over a d6 out of necessity
rather than desire and maybe that's okay
but it just looks so weird yeah I agree
and you also open up the c7 square yeah
so maybe that was better
okay he didn't instead he played b4 and
we had Bishop d7 and after d5 the
exchange is on the one thing you can say
for Artemyev is that if the
simplification continues these pawns are
much weaker than the BNA pawn black
I need some pressure here so if white
gets more access look for these pawns to
start being real targets Bishop b2 is an
idea that you have to keep mine hitting
the a3 pawn in the rook at the same time
I think we're all seeking of one here
and then but should be to right and then
rub c7 that if you take I hit up seven
at the end
yeah that's annoying why do that to me
why you gotta be so rude I'm human too
yep
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna be rude on that
seventh ring for that King actually that
doesn't look bad for black this Bishop
b2 okay let's do it
rook c7 and Bishop e6 you're gonna force
me to win a piece oh I was testing you
barely past f+ not have four instead
yeah you gave me no choice but the wind
material you give me no choice but to
crush you so what's he do now it feels
like blacks should be okay but you need
some precise moves okay he's gonna take
with the bishop I assume because of the
threat of rook c7 but maybe I'm wrong
maybe taking what the rook is also
possible yeah okay he goes forward
because I think now when you get the
rook down you have double threats on f7
and b7 as the Brooks simplify themselves
so so ever see a plate challenging for
the C file you if you leave the C file I
could probably my work on c2 and just
challenge your name e to the B Sherman
g7 is a great piece yeah really the best
piece on the board really yep okay so
Chris shook has trade so rook b5 b6 and
b7 the same time but you're not only to
is very vulnerable your back rank isn't
doing so hot either
you just take on e2 and play Brooks T to
check you take on e2 you should probably
make a draw obstacle or bishops doesn't
seem to be too difficult right should
simplify itself out
and rook aid nice move is Chris shook
gonna try to push this yeah and suddenly
the transition is real the bishop here
by far the better pieces here in the
open position if we want to remind
everybody about why the bishop pair are
what they are right this is an open
board where they thrive
too many diagonals hardly enough time
for white to deal with it in fact how do
you deal with the a pawn if you put the
rook on a2 then the bishop comes to e6
and actually you can't even stay there
this is this is a this is why the bishop
pair are dangerous so it gives up the a3
pawn and takes the b7 pawn but now b4 is
clearly we crook b3 next it's gonna yep
be a move you can't go f3 here because
now f3 is hanging thanks to the bishop
and rook teaming up on the square and
the knight doesn't have any great square
to go to maybe Knight f4 but this is a
good move though from a prophylaxis over
protecting preventing Bishop h3 Ram yeah
a very good move I like it
the bishop on b7 is so vital here
protects the f3 square and yeah it's not
there's not enough material left for
black to claim to have any real winning
chances okay let's go rook b3 is you
were suggesting though guys so Brooke b3
maybe pawn f3 they're not possible
Fisher comes to e6 and you still got
agar before now I've got an ID for there
okay and if I trade you're taking e6 and
saying it's a draw
obstacle bishops or I'm check meeting
you with 96 rupee a mate oh you 4b - you
got fortunate yeah simplify let's show
everybody the line we're talking about
we're getting too far in our analysis I
would say our Grandmaster heads but we
know I'm not 194 I have three first I'm
sorry yeah open 94 might be good yeah
actually right away accidentally played
a better move you know the point is now
if you take again Roberts idea was that
you hit the rook and this is mate take
away the e7 square yeah from the King
the knight guards it so that was his
tactic that we were analyzing in our
head there and if you take here now I
take actually with a tempo guarding it
and hitting the bishop so even better
mm-hmm okay
well we're kind of getting that idea in
94 although with the bishop on e5 the
King can escape so no longer mating nets
for Grichuk to worry about say that
again the King's NFA things on f8 no no
the the differences the bishop was still
in g7
King Kent goes on f8 he can't go to h7
we're good good mate um so 94 played
here and the threat maybe what is Brooke
thinking about hmm
it's a great question as you know it's
this move okay when age five now angle
h4 yeah or h3 first yep
the trait okay I think we're gonna get a
peaceful result here as much as this has
been a yeah a thrilling back-and-forth
game here said with only a hint of
sarcasm and we appreciate the questions
than she had yeah I know it's important
we want to break down all the all the
the basic ideas here but in the end it
looks like the simplification that's
just gonna lead to peace you're doing a
little careful for white for your time I
don't know what he's thinking about but
you can't go route d6 here okay you
could have tried it but you can get
yourself into more trouble than you
realize that some of these and games
yeah it's true because once the pawns
are separated you've got all kinds of
weaknesses here right rooks coming in
rook me three here okay King e5 makes
sense ch4 yeah he doesn't write as I
played it actually no he didn't I played
it lol for seconds
no p3 10 seconds to 5 seconds by king D
5 I still expect a draw but because time
scrambles are about to happen don't
don't look away maybe we'll see
something wild that's essentially a draw
p5 Pete could be 5 there oh he does it
the second time the King D things I'm
not sure of a king be 5 rook f6 you you
get the b-pawn but you have the Jeep on
I don't know who that favors right white
rings the king over to free the rook now
that the king guards the pawn the rook
can do things rook F for one mm-hmm or
Brooksie for you do not want to put the
rook on g4 it's a very weird spot for ya
it defends everything oh oh oh who's
gonna win of the king of hunting if you
had to go for it he now he loses the
people under King 6 would have allowed
rook c8 everybody and our Jimmy of his
one upon
will it be enough to win the game Wow
two seconds let Brooke f1 Creek that way
if you go be 74 op1 check check keep
checking to put your rope behind the
beep on yep
oh hey just wow that was a huge mistake
yeah but the King's going up kindy 3 I
know I was gonna say like now who's
winning look at the time he has no time
he's gonna get himself made it I thought
I was no king of three fingers three
first or King be three yeah point five
he made it the server gives him the
increment back and are we gonna just uh
Wow they were both like you know I dude
I just don't have the energy for this
give me the draw here Wow six minutes
left this you said in the last match we
were wondering how many total games were
played that being of course Aronian
versus firuze you have you missed it
shame on you but this match has really
had very few games played yeah this has
been a total of seven seven games in the
five-minute portion is that about out
that's like less than average that's
less than average right it feels like
these games have been really long yeah
they have been I mean yes we saw Aronian
beat through just seven to two so they
had nine games and I feel like that's
more normal when we can get our you know
smarter chests statistician on it to see
what the average numbers do something
yeah wow that's great
Robert has anagram of the day becomes
beer shorts today's show brought to you
by Champy's you can now put a beer in
your shorts I love it you've referenced
in the jam be a champion B's they're
super comfy my body will be so happy you
know someone clip that for Robert yeah
Jambi but speaking of beer shorts that
that could be a new nickname for you it
works
next time you wear your jams cami champs
alright 94s played what do we got here
like a weird grünfeld no you see this
with the bishop here yeah okay so if you
take on c3
white takes the pawn back you in the d5
pawn but why is generally happy about
this structural change cuz you Vic is
gonna be so mad that just gave free huge
advertising to 10,000 viewers to your
buddy you better appreciate so of course
he's gonna appreciate Champy's Nick you
should get a pair Janet
all right Fisher before bring the queen
up try to get a big center yeah maybe
three ooh you know like not just as
challenge the you know you're saying the
Queen shouldn't be ahead of the bishop
when there's a bishop challenging that
diagonal interesting III instead now put
the bishop on g3 indeed because the
trade will help the h-file and I guess
he just wants to be shipped e3 and e4
and the one thing about his move order
is it opens up c4 in some positions yeah
instead of g3 definitely okay raka Roka
and then you can push either pawn I like
this for Grichuk actually ya know it's
the problem for black is you always be
worried about which pawn is going to
push and how you're gonna deal with it
so the then this you for white is you
can't move his net in f3 you want to
play 95 but you lose the g2 pon so if
you Castle and move the night you get
made it yeah you heard it here kids you
also heard it the stat man looking fast
for us 9.2 is the average number of
games played we have a lot of history
now in the speeches championship it's
been a few years so that kind of makes
that's even cooler I really do like that
the more we do this like now we're
referencing like the great match of 2016
you know Aronian grew shook which was a
great match by the way but yeah so 9.2
is the average games in the 5 minute
portion so we're a little behind not
that far as our 8th game right yes yeah
I like how Chris check also he's he was
really large like his faces in front of
the camera before yeah and now he's
hiding from us got back yeah all right
so 94 it this makes a lot of sense you
have a bishop and queen on the diagonal
you might as well plug the square and by
h7 yeah and also this is a threat this
is a real threat even with Chet King e2
and you mate you may be in trouble here
yeah the night may have wanted too far
yeah an a5 takes away the square for the
Queen right so that makes c4 even more
likely yeah and a note for some of our
less experienced viewers taking on g3 is
generally speaking a bad decision when
is it rook still on each one yep it
regardless of the fact that I can take
with check if you if when you take here
the H file being open is a is usually
frowned upon yes
and here it definitely is because the
hsm pond is hanging first so what is he
gonna do a six you have to consider it
for white right at some point boy I love
that movie there's like a six a and C
for coming it just doesn't feel in fact
so much so that he plays b5 we called it
I think I think why should why doe get
castled now but yeah now a castle yeah a
six with Tempe get canceled
then go to work with rookie five and c4
mm-hm
Castle yeah Castle is there some reason
why he doesn't want it was cuz when the
trade happens on g3 he still loves the
idea of opening the rook so he's he's
trying to keep that rook on that
potentially dangerous age for as long as
possible I was talking about how you
couldn't move that night because the g2
font was hanging but now there's a night
blocking the Queen's access to G to the
ninety five jump makes a lot of sense
hitting this Bishop run c6 you can't
afford to lose that one but you don't
really want to give your dark square
Bishop either so this is a nice
advantage for Kershaw here and f3 is a
threat kicking the night away I love you
three let me have for ya oh this smells
like trouble for grow shook our time the
grind Bishop takes c7 go get yourself a
pawn big guy then Brooke F to see a and
the C fund let every anyway because I
take the night while you get my Bishop
you it's fair point yeah do you like it
starting with f3 also that's three right
away also interesting but I just don't
see why not grab the pawn when you can't
really stop f3
yeah that makes a lot of sense Chris
shook is thinking about it the one issue
with f3 right away let's analyze it when
you take and take as good as this looks
the F file prevents you from getting
counseled right that could be a little
irritating right so if he does it but I
think with the bishop on it in my line
in my line there's no open a file take
with the fish money for oh yeah right
even better now maybe take C 7h 4 is
another move that comes to mind but
perhaps doesn't work actually bit of fun
move by you okay I do like taking c7
because guess what's coming next
what about Knight stakes have three it's
a moment that might have to your I think
I think our team is losing this game and
send grow shook into the 3-minute
portion with a one-game lead because I'm
liking liking Sasha's approach here
I guess the prom with 97 just take it
right especially now that my bishops
done it for it's a piece right yep well
we have the closing time for the
five-minute segment don't get Semisonic
on me
but I think that I can call this one
grow shook is gonna have a one-game lead
as we head into the three minute portion
although he has had great positions in
earlier games and some I guess I'm
calling a little too earlier right but
he's up on the clock as well and just a
great spot Bishop err extra pawn the one
problem in the petition is the c3 pawn
mm-hmm but that pawn on e4 and d4 that
looks pretty nice thank you for the sub
there Matt appreciate the two months
means you're new to the channel thanks
for being here takes put the Queen on d2
Wow
f5 he's all-in he has to be but he is
all in so what do you do about this if
you take on f5 and then take on e5 just
take it all seriously you're so greedy
the sub love thanks everybody
no I think take and take everything he's
gonna do it okay yeah look at you
hey Queen c5 check take why not take the
pawns Cramer
why does rupiah make you Bert it's just
winning all right a lot of pause oh geez
look that's actually nice because if you
take a five you take a free board you go
f4 and just say hold e5 say I got you I
got you
Oh actually f4 runs right into F takes
e4 and then Queen c5 checking you
wouldn't want oh very nice okay well uh
we'll show that in a second but that
actually show now what the heck let's
back this thing of it show the tactic
the robber just spotted if F four takes
here and when you take what tempo the
Queen gets check and then f4 falls
that's not what white we're wanted nope
okay we're uh I'm not positive white
really wanted this either
you still up the e pawn but g6 is coming
to undermine the defense good point no
you have to get something quickly right
you how do you do it
actually it's hard to get a I mean if
you have a rook here it's over right
right but and King takes G to Brook e5
maybe this move preventing g6 take with
the rook I like that but it's silver key
v okay rookie rookie - rookie v I put
the Oh dirty dog bishop c6 there protect
my very nice pass g2 pond yeah this has
become much more clear yeah shook has uh
it's not shown the best technique here
and we already know he's missed a couple
wins and if we're if you're just joining
us we're not just saying that he
literally had a couple games that were
one move away from a victory one of them
which he lost so grow shook is uh maybe
maybe gonna find himself into three min
as far as total form overall I mean I'm
not trying to make the storyline like or
shook whatever but it does feel like
sasha has played a little bit better at
this point and so even though the match
is tied if you're just getting here
that's kind of why the tone seems to be
like or shook is letting it getting away
right now that can always change right
as the time controls get faster maybe
our Tim you've gets better so rookie
five it easy planted meat over beef or
perhaps just okay right awkward and if
you can take take bring the king up you
take on g2 with your king I'll take on
e4 that's always my point
haha very nice very nice oh he's gonna
be up g4 just take out five is hmm
yeah Bishop g4 take a five again thanks
for the subs there may be h3 is slow is
that it what do you think that would be
the highest class waiting move probably
brookie five still old maybe I say very
unconfident Lee so he allowed it and
rook f1 no Brooklyn is Bishop takes f5
yeah but there's rook takes a five and
East seven it's so weird yeah you get
away with it oh he goes for it Bishop
takes f5 rook takes now I take with that
rook that for yeah exactly
okay but in the end
c7 rookie 5 rook takes b5 rookie 7 rook
b7 oh that's really nice that's really
nice me seven king of seven Hawking of
seven saves your day so it's actually
keep so he'll play 21
c4 here c4 no c4 was a good move
c4 cakes oh that would be a charity
seven yeah okay we got to back up and
show that Roberts move I think was
winning up he played my rook e1 but c4
the point everyone was on takes you have
check first and then when the King moves
east seven wins on the spot but after
check me you've got fate there ah maybe
why so maybe Brooke d1 my god the best
chance
okay does end up getting a 7 so sasha
has winning chances although again maybe
not as good as he would have liked mercy
6 here you're gonna win the c3 fawn 8
seconds for gosh ook vs. 20 seconds for
our team you have this has been a this
has been a great man this is no one
wiggling themselves to a to a real lead
yet rook c6 do it rook c64 say 7 then
put the rook on a 6 that's a good move
because if king of three now you go rook
c6 tablature check should go he's doing
the first rank the problem is it forces
the King out network h6 but it doesn't
work ASAP III always keeps QP 3 any
losses yeah I was gonna win so can B 3 4
4 C 4 is gonna happen what a move rook a
for C 4 you can't take with the pawn cuz
the brook and you can't take with the
rook because the rook moves and you get
a queen there c4 c5 resigns
yeah what c5 resigns called it nailed it
we are going to have our first break the
speeches championship action continues
our double-header
second matches underway with that we
have a four and a half three and a half
lead for Alexandra Schuch we're gonna
take a very very quick break and when we
get back all 9380 three of you will be
here because if not you're hurting
Roberts feelings
[Music]
a Premium Membership at chess calm will
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50,000
puzzles to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you play turning every game into a
chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level and
we are back with the 2019 speed chess
championship our second match of the day
continues on of course we have Vladislav
artemiev vs. alexandre shook and the 5
minute portion did not disappoint not
just our our perspective as chess fans
but also the smarter chess predictions
pretty much right in line with what we
thought it was gonna be so we're gonna
get ready here for the three-minute
portion to begin our players have taken
their seats from their break and the
games will be taking off here any moment
any moment Robert aren't any of looks
like it might be asleep there I was
trying to figure out you know I could
see him blinking or something yeah he's
really trying to give space space
between him and the camera yep you know
the camera likes his space so the games
should begin here any second and Robert
any any other takeaways obviously the
scoreboard tells us exactly what you
need to know right the most concrete
point of view as well grow shook has a
one-game lead but any other takeaways
from the five-minute portion about how
the players are playing yes been
interesting to see how Artemyev has
played especially the white side he's
playing g3 Bishop g2 b3 Bishop b2 he's
not going for sort of mainstream theory
right and I can't help but wonder if
that's hurting him in this match thus
far because Chris Oak is not the type of
player easy to spend his time regardless
right and he's not the type of player
who is going to be shocked by you
playing b3 or he's played in Hakkari
Nakamura enough times to know how to
handle it and so it seems like he's been
doing just fine with the black pieces
which
well it's not gonna be a good thing for
our Timmy of going down the stretch of
this match well we talk about that a lot
and you and I know that of all the
players who come in to the speeches
championship every year
Sasori shook is probably somebody who
takes it as seriously as anybody right
so we're just being a little critical of
the fact that when you're facing a guy
like this you really need to play your
main openings play your theory right
you're not you're not looking to trick
him into some sort of sideline blitz
specialty stuff and so our Timmy of not
doing that necessarily with with his
approach in the in the match so far
although as you look at this one here
what's going on we've got a weird to
kind of double fee and ket already but
still something that we would really
kind of like go shoot position honestly
yeah because of two big pawns in the
center
it doesn't seem hard for blacks to kind
of defend the position the palm of c2 is
a potential liability that requires
defense as the Queen's staring it down
Brooksie one fall by c4 is an option for
white at some point but or c4 right away
apparently according to or Timmy up he's
not that worried about the isolated
c-pawn I'm wondering if he'll be proven
wrong yeah like Bishop g4 is just one
option you might want to try to sac it
at some point so okay I was wondering if
you want to go out of you way to play b6
but the problem was there were diagonal
tactics Oh Bishop f5 first a threat
maybe if if white plays something like
rook c1 is put the rook on c8 which one
maybe this one yeah you can also put
your Bishop on e4 at the right moment
say goes off the diagonal yeah and the
thing is the e5 pawn is defendant for
the time being if you go c5 I can't even
consider taking it on c5 and just saying
you know you get my epon at your C pawn
but we have this kind of Grune fel dish
yeah ending with the two on you on one
of the Queen's that I like it going to
be three played now and crow shook
immediately responds with Bishop b4 so
what c5 okay but this is what we're just
talking about it's a different you know
slightly different position because the
Queen moved instead of a rook but take
on c5 I would take that Bishop takes e5
yeah I mean Plus if the trade happens on
e5 and you end up trading off the light
square bishop that probably helps black
as well yeah it's some attacking
possibilities we
typically when you have a fee in keto
and is the bishop and on g2 or on b2 you
want to keep it in front of your King to
help defend the sum of the squares are
now more vulnerable so if you just
imagine that Bishop just disappears h3
f3 become targets we don't have to
imagine anymore you don't
the bishop is gone right now the bishop
is gone what about just Queen takes t5
here Queen takes e5 the rook comes to c1
and hits the bishop but there's a queen
b6 or something maybe six okay defend
the bishop and trade Queens although if
we trade that in the end a five falls
right that's true because that's a
better version for white in this better
so you got to be a little careful maybe
you're gonna move like g6 first oh well
he's more aggressive intentions and mine
in fact he wants to take b7 sorry take
c5 with the night yep and where's this
Queen going Knight a5 you've been thrown
at some moment so you always to be
careful as black watch out for 9 to 5
and tactical shot hey McQueen on e7 and
she's guarding a lot of things right now
so that would be ill-advised to allow
the knight to come to a5 next 95z huger
how do you deal with you might even play
Bishop b6 now because of it it's a rook
ca ca it's an item 5 what's so kind of
Queen e6 or something yeah 26 it's just
a big trade I guess but Bishop e3 and
again everyone if Knight f5 were
thinking 26 although now I'm not so sure
because Queen 66 would be a problem yes
so you have to move somewhere else g5
okay that's the answer
maybe e4 before looks reasonable I have
a hard time deciding who let their
initiative escape there honestly seems
like black is doing quite decently here
watch out for that eise evan square
right why I would love to kick the Queen
out from the g5 squared to get access to
b7 h4 was a possibility for does just
that maybe right
Tempe the Queen but okay h4 Queen f6 and
worse the follow up yeah she's a queen
there right away
yep looks pretty steady what have you
take on c5 and just try to play with a
knight the problem is you're not doesn't
get to d5 quickly you know yeah
you want your knight on d5 if you're
gonna play against only I just put it
there at one time
just one time okay I'll let it slide
all right so tactics available no 96
checking g7 guarding the Queen and not a
not a lot to it now the question is just
black want the ladies off the board I
guess so
answers that question to make sure he
can bring his King quickly to e6 okay
checks out I think that the endgame
looks to be roughly equal yep
and again you I'm looking at these ideas
Bishop takes e5 and getting my knight
into the game but the bishop me just sit
on a seven the King will run to e6 for
black and it seems like all is okay so
now I was gonna say the D fall zone for
black but the C file has to be dealt
with I have this feeling that ogre shook
sang game will be a little bit better
here okay the f6 pawn is not really
under fire because I can pin it and win
it i watch that the time Lachi 13 second
13 seconds for kasuga wasn't paying
attention
rook d2 happens so here king e2 which is
much better yeah kingi to rook d2 would
have allowed Bishop takes c3 as a threat
okay so right as I say I think we're
shook we'll get a better version of
saying him apparently Bishop e7 being
allowed was a blunder
because f6 falling is not ideal you
can't even play Bishop h4 now if you're
our Jimmy of bring it to Chi 3 and then
it's not so easy to convert this your
one pawn as white but you don't have at
the time I guess the time is huge that's
huge but the problem for white as well
as like rook a5 it's a moment will force
you to your work to be tied down to the
defense of the a to pawn and something
that's probably not worth knowing yet
but you know how I always talk about
this is the a to pawn the a8 corner and
some circumstances not the same colors
the bishop not in Kansas not anymore at
least yeah it comes up for I think or
Brook h4 h4 it definitely has a 7 but
the 95 is a little yes so he plays
Knight c3 first then I think we'll get
back to this idea very difficult to hold
this position less than 5 seconds yeah
how did it do something a 5 was a big
threat to remove the garden I and c5 and
now the Knights trying to go to d6 I
guess but even still there it's not fun
or Kim you just seems
super patience super poised knows that
he doesn't have to do too much to win
this game because gooks time pressure
may end up winning the game for him yep
so he's just kind of sitting tight here
doesn't even go for rock h4 keeps the
rook and it's most flexible spots I like
it just good technique right just not
being overly committed to the winning
plan a 94 check over 66 is just as good
I do
oh wait unless there's something better
but nice oh you guys rook c6 okay oh
good you can trade though put the knight
on b5 and you still got an e pawn we
know how to push definitely do we're
about to see this match levelled up to a
5 here just push that thing rook is like
fending this off though with very few
very few seconds you got one second Dan
right thanks for being obvious no but
seriously he is defending really well I
mean keep waiting for this one to be
over but our team F has not leveled the
score yet and now he's down to 3 seconds
crooks really did an excellent job he'll
win but looking watch out for the 88
though by taking issue Falls East 6 king
D 6 work CID 7 the a 6 that's an e a
pawn runs Wow
what a finish oh my gosh no it's wait ok
there it is that's the final touch you
needed yeah that's one ok and the reason
everybody once the next game it gets
underway will will bring up the analysis
board but the reason is that there we go
we'll we'll bring up the analysis board
here and show you is that in this final
spot black can't pass if the bishop
moves over here we have a 7 if the King
moves back we get the King in and
eventually to b7 so there you have it
that is why it ended the way it did and
that is why as we come back to the live
game we have a tied match look at that
they said this was gonna be a nail-biter
by day I mean us mm-hm and by us I mean
we and mine said it was gonna be a
nail-biter and my we do you mean French
for yes I mean the Royal we the
collective unit French is pretty royal
language
focus on the chess game Dan nickname in
high school one of the only real
nicknames I had focus on your chess game
today this opening is very strange
because White has upon a five and those
like whites made like four extra moves
black is currently up a pawn it's this
double C pawn that just was captured and
now this b6 square is extremely
vulnerable if that night can land on b6
and that Brooks has to send a seven
black is not gonna be very happy now can
sit on b8 which is a much better square
so he's not gonna put an i b6 just yeah
I probably played g3 OD force hanging
never mind yeah a lot of pressure here I
forget about that so your d5 oh hey I
was right yeah g3 played I like it
he's just saying I'm gonna sacrifice a
pawn if need be and just developed very
quickly but this looks a bit suspicious
it's a Bishop c5 here can't even Castle
cuz you'd be casting into a discovery 83
Queen chief or maybe hmm there's also 94
94 Ellis Bishop b4 check yeah then I
move my King because I'm threading
things like we need for check to pick up
your Bishop it's true alright this is
the first idea and I think this makes
sense because you can even trade Queen
take on c6 and you've got 96 and then
trade Queens and play with the advanced
Queen side so that's why the night ghost
f5 instead so take on d8 take on d8 play
night or just King e2 ignored the
pollination I like it and then put one
work on c1 run take him bake king he -
there it is look as I'm playing it he
played it I've played him faster grow
shook take that Rick you have a rock hd1
burrkc one not gonna be too fun prime
time so if you did that on purpose or
not but good job right don't you'll
never know some people called Deion
Sanders prime time then they call me
rhyme time the roles of reversing here I
don't know what to do with you I'm
trying to focus on the D file put the
bishop back put a Brooke on d1
and now it's even material again yeah
the night's coming to e5 the ponte five
is great and just really cements that
pawn on e6 holds everything jail limits
the Bishop on c5 can't go to b6 ever
made mine I can go to b6 some moment
alright so let's take it but the Kings
are gonna be 17 this and yet
everything's protected mm-hmm the
bishops might be very strong and
actually the opponent b2 is gonna be a
big weakness some of these lines which
is why he put 95 didn't just trade yeah
because the prospect of King g7 rook to
b8 wouldn't have been too fun yes
somehow our Jimmy was coordinating just
in time actually as you can still play
King g7 yep but Knight d3 is a little
scary ah something that Bishop out of
sorts in fact his threats of b4 after 93
Danny used to be known as jug of water
Danny so they wouldn't confuse him with
the other Danny's in the glass
let's see what's what can i retentive do
here he ain't spending a lot of time in
this move and he's now down 30 seconds
with just a minute left
yeah the three-minute portion not as
much time to figure out these critical
moments big Vlad needs to get the medal
the new big Vlad from Russia will never
be as good as the old big flat you
really do that I do 93 yeah just seems I
think we'll get night he takes the
bishop here probably cuz 93 was met by
94 and save the bishop so he didn't like
that just it's gonna poke it up on May 6
yeah 94 here's possible you can't second
85 is 95 check bring the knight to be 6
more foot the rook on c1 belts illogical
yeah let's see 6 guard c8 rook b8 now 13
Bishop takes a 5 removing the guard of
this bishop actually have this night I
was actually shook actually shakes his
head like what was I think he listened
to
why did I put the night there I was
actually just a blunder we have a
question from Daryl Morey how many
seconds equals a pawn when under one
minute on both sides that's a great
question and exactly what we would think
the general manager of the Houston
Rockets would would think about always
trying to look for that statistical edge
and we know the answer Daryl and we're
not gonna tell ya we need to advantage
over other broadcast you think we're not
gonna tell you the the answer our
analytics team would advise us not to
share that information with the general
manager of the Houston Rockets Leela
doesn't speak human yet Daryl all right
roasted beef or I don't look good for
black o h7 is hanging and you're not
going full Fisher yeah no way to trap
the bishop although f5 would be an
irritating move that's true okay I can't
get that Bishop back as fast you'd like
he saves the H Vaughn
okay but white is sort of weathered the
storm I think we're likely headed for a
peaceful result given the opposite code
bishop nature of this one but who knows
the bishop on c4 is excellent yeah and
if you could get pressure on e6 does it
I like it double cuz you're threatening
both a doubling and a fourth rank poking
it doesn't sound fun classic Daryl thank
you for the subs Daryl you're the man
supporting the channel we love you buddy
yeah rook d4 wouldn't playable cuz
Bishop e5 to be careful what you were
whenever your opponent's a bishop you
want to always look if you're putting
your piece on a color square of that
bishop just to the time it's time
fresher each four is a big threat house
does need subs if that's one thing he
needs
I need subs for what this is my channel
this is your channel it's not nice try
though you're like this is your channels
of people can't gift subs rook to b3
threatens beef oh look a black just
bishop deep there was no a6 capture
possible because you had Bishop you to
another station okay folks
do fix it now Brooksie to Bishop e2
though he's just fine Bishop c3 okay do
you see Christian oh my oh my god that's
what that's what I do that's my job to
freak out on camera oh Kruk not thrilled
with that right there he was trying to
move and the time ran out Wow Wow we
have two victories in a row now for
Artemyev not a game that was supposed to
be won by black at least not like that
we didn't expect it to happen right but
that's why it's speech yes the time
pressure is real he's going back to his
nakamura roots here with a little b3
action yes our would be three but he got
well I mean if he continues to do this
I'm not gonna I'm not I just I don't
think it's gonna be great results all
right he's up a game right now in the
match 504 and a half but I just don't
think the repertoire is uh something he
should be should be using grow chute
gonna play main lines and challenge it I
mean what don't you look at the position
and say black is already at least equal
here yeah doing fine black is very solid
right so all right well obviously as
games like that just proved the opening
is only a very small part of it yep
right and Darrell said Christian should
pull out his hammer yeah go to go to
tail call up his buddy Vlad Dobrev and
that's doable
Nikolai's I love that so let's see
what's gone with be forcing you have
this two-on-one advantage on the a and B
files for black and the C pawn that
someone can push to c5 to cut off the
bishop from the action but at the same
time you push defy becomes a target so I
like 94 much better yeah and let's see
queen c8 protect that Knights of now
right yeah in Queen c7 would have
allowed Knight d5 with tempo
Queen CA makes sense I think c5 might be
coming yeah especially now the queen is
on the C file you know you don't really
want to allow rook then to come to see
one and put pressure on that Queen so
let's see what does sieve elephant means
it means Siberian elephant thank you for
the question
and for answering that Robert you're
very welcome Danny a3 know where that
toad was coming for a bit okay from one
friend to another so let's see where you
would need what are you doing
Susannah can peel skin okay look at me
alright a3 is played that's not a bad
idea when you're trying to trade off a
weak isolated pawn for a healthy Pesce
but if the tactical tension goes away
black is positionally doing just fine
that's c4 pawns weak in fact maybe he'll
go after it right away yeah we keep
talking about if you trade the fiend
kind of Bishop there will be vulnerable
squares in your Kings side right so if
you know you take on b7 I take out my
queen you're already looking at some
kind of threats with Knight f3 check if
I can remove your night away from the d4
square yeah and how do you just you got
a deal with this deal right
yeah can you I'm right at what point do
you take on before you allow black take
on a3
I just don't know how to deal with this
right now he's gonna take and then c5 I
assume but nicely for comes anyway so I
really like what's happening here shoot
getting the weight that oh it doesn't
butter a piece I think he thought he
could take with the pot why couldn't a
Gumby - like 90 HP - okay Knight takes
b7 I take t1 and then went before yeah
he's putting the pawn anyway - oh
there's some knight c6 stuff is looking
kind of annoying yeah and the main game
he's winning that ball right
in the main game weight 96 weight only
96 Queen d7 night take c7 check you take
back Bishop III and you've Queen c7 rook
c5 okay rook has stolen upon will he be
punished find out in just a few moments
we return we will be here 48 seconds for
our Jimmy of and Queen a1 okay you got
the battery hoping for knight c6 next
that's your goal and probably I need to
bring the Queen back to b7 anyway guard
a7 guard c6 what's she thinking those
are very reasonable he played it now 94
to g5 kind of ideas are scary yeah I
love that night Ashley would be mate yep
1994 teaching bughouse doubles night
mates night mates what you're always
showing me look at my position for once
see the pieces I need stay ahead in the
clock yeah that's a that's a good bug
house inside inside joke alright Queen
did G for Queen h3 Knight g4 Maybrook
have to c8 here there it is just keeping
an eye out to c6 and black is up a pawn
you could put Bishop c5 at some moment
if you want to kind of chase that night
hmm
I just take that thing how cuz I came
with my second rook on see it like I was
about to blunder so don't listen to me
like what if I trade in playbook c8 but
I can't do that because there's a queen
on 86 doesn't work h5 just go for it
H 5 H 4 H 3 yeah hold nothing back the
last game of the year last game of the
year not yet but kind of diamond
remember real Greco wants us to make
that doubles team happen bug house team
wrenching house oh it's happening don't
you worry doesn't even know it's
happening right now it's happening right
now because time is not linear its
liquid in a straw quantum physics
figured out
all right
h5 you're up a pawn if you're black h5
is good cuz it also frees the back rank
makes a7 as a threat you know you just
took the words right literally grab them
like Ursula Ariel I was like give me
your voice that was weird little
mermaids been on the brain lately
watched it recently book d1 rook H one
problem we have three working it here
comes Knight e4 no diggity yep h4 it's
all good it's all good in the hood for
black h4 looks
delicioso Dora so is 94 actually it's
running night 6 f2 ah both good
well what Sasha he's a game of Chiklis
bring it right back and then you lose e5
now that you've given me a what is he
doing so that's good shoot gets a little
tease no time I know but he had more
time than his opponent I mean well a
moment before nice gift - oh that's good
Knight g5 was oh thank you if I was
still coming though the rook has to move
95 92 I've traps the rook out 90 to go
sick down is Wow just take that and then
from d3 he's only a 5 seconds 4 seconds
2 seconds rook e8 rook e8 was good and
he missed it he's settling on the draw
shuka has how many games has he let get
away already ton a ton ok play for the
win a4 no it's not quickened doesn't
enough time there were comes the h1 just
in time
you can yell a4 like that any time
though permission Christian shakes his
head he should shake his head yeah
again two games were like a move away
from winning and at that point you could
just see he just he got too fancy if we
bring up the analysis board I mean it
was a black some blacks game to win for
sure I mean it may still be good here I
mean I was calling for rook e8 after the
e-file opened keep the pressure but
couldn't be 3 check I guess okay so
but for sure back here Robert you called
for it I mean with the Queen on f3 94
threatened Knight takes F 2 and then
rook t1 winning and h4 was also just
very strong I think he just missed this
though I think I don't think he saw this
the whole point everyone is okay you're
threatening a million things and it
takes rook d1 is resides so Wow back to
the live game but again it's it's a one
game lead right now for our Kimia man
there's no way you can't feel the khushu
cos uh someone's a little a miss yeah he
just said that knockout punch yes now
having it right now yep but he's been
very solid he's in many advantageous
positions and here we see he's the two
bishops he's claiming that's an
advantage and the thing is there's not
much space for either side right now
black is rock-solid b7 to d5 to f7 to h5
like all these light square pawns and
only once I had a light square bishop
and that's white but with all the pawns
on the light squares that bishops not
doing too much limited yeah and so it's
gonna be a very intense positional
battle from here on out God you just
like set the tone for something that
sounds so epic just you know trying to
get back to the chest like you told me
trying to be serious in super-cereal I'm
taking I'm gonna take that Darrell I'll
take that I'll take that GM norm from
the Rockets all right rook d1 played you
highlighted the fact that there's
tension in the position and the black
has control the light scores with the
pawns but we know the positionally 4
it's a go for white often in fact rook
d1 might prepare nice e5 and e4 to
follow yep
in fact me likey yeah most that night on
c5 well I don't know what he's waiting
for
sarah michelle gellar / jennifer Love
Hewitt what are you waiting for come on
Benson yeah no one cares about that
those details from a horror movie they
care when the main female star yells in
the road what are you waiting for
so I don't know why I'm getting mad at
you okay I know I feels just like in her
anger no we're doing fine
no we're not well I'm over you so anyway
we're gonna I mean you're right though
boy has a play for efore ideas yep
oh we're not but he's my one f1 in
some moment I actually really think 95
was better than what he did unless there
was some sort of tactic on d4 to
undermine that I okay all right back
back to the present position where white
does have an advantage in space but
black holding solidly all the scores the
manner and now 5 here we go here we go
that makes that bish 1g too much more
alive which is my main concern of
playing with a c5 yeah because what if I
take on d5 well the problem is
nightguard c8 it right away
I was doing my queen back to be one oh
really
I was hoping that my bishop would break
free yeah actually that's uh not a bad
point cuz even here the bishop pair
opening the position looks good which
means you probably won't take on e3 you
probably yeah and this like oh he goes
for a 5 I think so right Knight e5 says
the bish runs you to not getting open
although the vision good f1 at the right
time a shout-out to Chris there for the
bits we appreciate it all the love bit
along day we love you love why not E 5
I'm with you ooh wow but now take it I
think this is getting much better for
Sasha I mean the bishop air obviously
has an advantage as the position becomes
open but what are you thinking here I
can take on d5 a very happy Bishop yeah
I don't know why he's spending so much
time unless there's something with takes
and Bishop f4 I was sitting here
wondering what is he doing he wants to
open the D file maybe hit the bishop kc5
bishop takes and then
before so how important is this mover
okay I was wondering if you might afford
to take on do you're saying the Paul is
hanging anyway that's the point
and I want to get my night there and yes
thread 97 check and look at the time
again right yeah
but the position looks really good for
cooking now he's up 10 seconds as well I
like it yeah this looks good
I mean you take on III I take with my
bishop now the D files open for my rook
if you play this I think he takes d4 now
yeah he's gonna put a knight on e4 so
instead he says no to that but we get
the exact type of structure we were
talking about we take g6 thing open
it was a threat to could he have played
it I don't think so I don't think so
let's show it real quick instead of
taking here there was this possible
sacrifice on g6
but after takes D - everything's guarded
by the night so nothing to it
so instead Sascha settles on the simple
approach so although g6 is still under
under the gaze of the Queen not quite
because she's defending but keep an eye
on it and Queenie 4 is the threat to
hitting b7 hainan 94 so black is be very
careful with that in mind for now
extremely tactics tactics and you can't
really move your knight
I guess you're there but take on b7
they'll take on b7 the then Knight takes
a 4 check he's a bit annoying oh my gosh
they made king h2 there so he'd simply
try to keep the bishop oh the pin pin is
real rookie - well you gotta watch out
cuz you're movin night there's still
Bishop takes f7 check ideas this is good
no idea you can take up seven in it oh
no you can't takes P seven that was a
good decision okay Kruk got a convert on
this one too much
games that have gotten away in the time
scramble he's definitely winning here up
upon with the bishop pair in the endgame
move that mission back to e4 or f3 the
knight is pinned yep
Wow f5 I like the way he plays these
times ground positions he really puts
pressure on her shoot to find all the
right moves but this is Eddie was a good
decision to take on d4 rooks he said
yeah six is coming in g6 is a problem
Queen c7 well that caught me off guard
yeah I don't know why the Queen trade
was the end of the world for black
reasonable I think the pawn g6 is you
highlighted being yeah I mean but still
you think what the Queen's off the board
you have better drawing chance now you
have three pawns for Queen g5 a five
here you go
let's go push them baby goes Queen g5
play h5 next before pushing baby yeah
there it is Queen takes g6 Queen takes
f5 cleans this one up looking like it
how many pawns you up enough is the
answer visually four would let a little
made on h7 Queen see a check picked up
the Bhishma that's what he missed but he
found it now yeah I missed it for a
second - and it's actually almost mate
unless you give up the bishop with check
because if King h7 there's Bishop b4 so
okay
very very nice win right there from
Alexander goshawk and we have a tied
match with about 27 minutes remaining
here everyone in the total game clock so
don't go anywhere if you're if you're
just getting here you're in for the
treat that we promised you a very very
close match between these two Russians
I picked Crow shook is the slight
favorite Robert picked Artemyev we both
agreed to yo grab a you want to grab a
cold one after this and talk it over
alright mommy beer shorts apparent I did
call you BA shorts i right over here and
thanks for being here regardless of
where you are if you one of our one of
the seven thousand nine or twenty five
who've been here all day cuz we've been
live for six and a half hours awesome
that long you're right
you're awesome thanks for being here
speaking of awesome what do thing over
this position nothing's really
awesome in it everything it's awesome
it's a good song Grandmaster tippy is
awesome playing guess the move over
there rockin it let's see so the F on
high five is a good pun for white mm-hmm
holding back b7 exactly but black and
still consider playing b6 at the right
moment you know look at the aid pawn to
b6 to open up the B file a name of the
poem b2 actually don't think white has
gotten that much of the opening yeah I
agree
everything is well defended for black
trading off the bishops I give you a 6
as possible even without rook f b8
honestly I just wanted to time it so
that if you capture me I just
immediately have yeah you immediately
have battery threats I dig it that's why
you're a grandmaster and I'm not pretty
sure that's not the reason why I'm a
grandmaster
look at those dancing heads that's a
close match yep back and forth back and
forth playing a little tennis volleying
over here yep well two heads become one
by the end of the match find out hey
rook FB 8 is met by night ft 2 which is
why it wasn't a threat everyone d4 is a
threat here it is because the Queen is
undefended and the pawn on c3 is pinned
Queen to d2 takes care of all that
though or Brooke a 4 I like that move
yeah you're gonna bring the knight and
double rooks quickly to hit a six that's
the goal but black can consider playing
a 5 it's a moment if necessary but
politics is definitive for the time
being the crook and the Queen are just
gonna stay put but what's blacks plan
when we look at position like this for
you don't think about plans because if
black does nothing and white can just
white doesn't know we talked about the
three Brooklyn pawn to b4 put United on
c5 she's gaining space and it's very
difficult for black so you're hardly
because black needs a concrete plan here
to be fair because he has more
positional weaknesses than why you got
to do something here yeah change the
dead change the direction
so he brings a dating to c4 and okay
beat that's what he wants yeah before
it's a moment and III and before
kryptonite played before with tempo and
then put a knight on c5 before here
before night on c5 in fact because this
night while you would think you're
giving up a permanent outpost square
everyone you can kind of get away with
this because this Knight is much more
likely to be traded by the move Knight
to d2 and this Knight coming to c5
either helps when a6 or forces you to
capture and give me a protected passer
and yes that rhymed
okay to a five I think you should have
played but before it's still possible he
goes 92 anyway he's saying that this a
pawn is gonna be pinned or it's gonna be
a target it's gonna be pinned and this
goes to show why nights instead of
bishops can be so good because this
Bishop on d6 can never contest for light
squares whereas you're like oh there's a
9 c4 I want to kick it out let me bring
my knife back there to do so yeah I like
it
and positionally white holes a lot of
the cards here because as the night gets
traded 85 okay yes the B file has some
pressure but a5 is the only real
weakness here the only isolated pawn and
that's kind of key as we're evaluating
the future of the position so Artemyev
in a good spot right now to regain his
lead also I've almost admitted on the
clock by the way I'm wondering when he's
gonna play b4 and just really ask black
how he plans to defend the Queen side I
mean to a five pawns also hanging right
so if I take on c4 it there it is before
I like it that's why I said why not oh
yeah that looks like a problem looks
good I don't know you defended Bishop c7
is not a fun move to play then you just
a lot of nine to c5 you're throwing a
take on c4 remove the guard of the gun
with the a pawn and straight up exactly
very difficult for black only 30 seconds
can you take a 5 in her miss oh I wonder
if he could have right there yeah
interesting question he didn't do it
clearly I tell me of you know he's up a
minute so better he's just the a pawns
pinned anyway
right it's not going anywhere for a
while um I see five Brooklyn but I
wonder if he missed his chance he played
that move very quickly let's back up to
the analysis board and actually see
whether that was possible because in
this position after the trade rook takes
a five was an intermezzo mezzo mizo and
I think then you win here
I mean what's what's the move that I'm
missing I think that was that was a
mistake
actually I mean from a if it ends up
being a position that we shook
ultimately holds we hit we will
definitely come back to that moment as a
big one
so he's defending it and you still can't
capture him before because the pawn is
pinned yeah but what's whites and eggs
but right now they're both under time
pressure I think our Kim you've let to
let this one slip may be king of one
okay nice if I wasn't sure about because
of Bishop d6 but I'm never gonna take it
and give you to pass pause right take on
before I can take before yeah I was
saying you wouldn't everyone take the
knight but his endgame still not so
comfortable right because the King keep
moving the King in can you - king d3 oh
yeah all right Kirk I was king of the
center can't go to even be 5 C 6 and B 5
what you need is white is to be able
attack a second weakness if go rook a to
2 F 3 years but it's too slow yeah very
very slow
Brooks from a2 can't go to f3 thank you
for the lesson no matter how hard you
try Robert said do it okay take out c5
there now what if we go taking on c5
instead of on a5 did winning in the King
appalled anything there was gonna be a
yeah to the Batcave
to the Batcave what could about there
wasn't making applying name cuz if you
got like to the beginning of it I was
gonna be a Brooke compositing yeah yeah
then we'll get going but we'll we'll
continue to figure this thing out here
on the analysis board right back here
like here yes right yeah I was imagining
everything coming off and if the rooks
were off the board here even this might
almost be winning for black but with the
two rooks on the board yeah king
plasto's never before checks I can't
yeah it's probably still the draw but
definitely something black to consider
because you could play the position
right play e5 two big pawns anyone I was
thinking but would have been interesting
all right it didn't happen we are back
to the live position here as the next
game in the three-minute segment rolls
on only 18 minutes remain
time flies when you're having fun the
three-minute portion we remain at
deadlocked at six and a half games of
peace I'm kind of a weird opening by or
10 me up here he played b5 on the first
move in this one so he's not afraid to
mess it up and Brooke is probably like I
need to punish this guy as far as games
or let's say matches were comparing
right in the Aronian Holly Reza match we
had a massive lead for the armenian 7 to
2 after 5 minutes neither player in this
match has ever had a two-game lead we
have had a one-game lead at most for
either player and both players have led
by one point at some point so this is
this is the definition of a
back-and-forth coin-flip match so we
hope you stay with us all the way to the
end because it's gonna be think it's
gonna be exciting I'm still totally up
in the air whether weather which players
better a bullet so yeah and we just saw
that ticker across the screen saying
that go shook us four and a half out of
six and there's six white games as far
it's a very good sign for him but that
also means that Artemyev is also
crushing with the white pieces yep you
know I've gotta figure that out for both
sides you know typical where white has a
better score you move first you kind of
dictate the action but then you just
show up their positions and right now
here are the white pieces in this game I
think we both agree that with this pawn
on a six and zero weaknesses
week of four white that we must like
Sasha's position you have to write it's
everything is equal except the structure
this is kind of the structure we had
last game except colors reversed right
yeah our Kimia was unable to convert by
the way I think he just that rook takes
a five we were right about that I think
he just missed that used to win yeah
okay again there's been a couple of
missed opportunities it seems either
that or we're seeing things which
wouldn't be surprised to hear that
either afterwards Knight b6 that's a
good transition if the knight trades
let's analyze that for white and that's
why you don't want to take because you
kind of fix your opponent's structure no
longer have just the isolated pawn there
it has it hey buddy buddy system so
instead you play queen d1 to make sure
that there is nobody system for the a
pond
another question is do you care exactly
I think you love that move you play
Bishop f1 first you just not care about
the bishop because of the 1930 Queen III
now it's not only that no you take your
first with tempo and then the end of the
line East 7 Falls ah looks for
interesting I guess you can take on b2
instead of gone Queen C like it's a lot
of I'm just gonna wind oh my gosh this
is just straight-up killer Kruk is up a
pond it has the bishop here yes he's up
the pawn and the compensation as they
say and the time well you are the best
chatter sigh mo one if we're the best
commentators you're the best chatter
called it no samesies no samesies my
kids still say that i think that's kind
of dorable I thought you said in which
cases make fun of you but now I know
it's from them it's normal from me so
okay let's see how white really makes
progress opposite colored bishops which
means that in certain end games it's
gonna be hard to press forward but in
games with Queens on the board an attack
can happen for example do Bishop d3
pause talking dirty on those light
squares exactly and then you might will
not be able to stop it so that's the
that's the trade off his end games often
give pretty good chances to hold more
middle games or earlier stages attack so
95 now giving up the beet soup onto
something that's certainly worth gotta
be considered right
probably Queen c2 though just keep that
pawn on the but look at this
to the Batcave Knight a5 rook b2 nice e6
your only move as Queen e8 cuz Queen c8
allows a four key mode so the Queen goes
to e8 and you're gonna tell me this
isn't I just I just like keeping my
extra pawns you know I like sacrificing
pieces rook a seven look how good this
would have been he didn't go for it he
played your move Queen c2 lame sauce c5
Knight a5 he's still better but I'm just
the player hate the game
what a diamond remember MBTs Master in
the Chesapeake chat says who are you
rooting for in the match Dani you're
Robert I'm not rooting for anybody
I don't root for people stop it
I don't so you stop it he went d5 which
I just had suggested the Knights coming
to c6 if black plays Knight e5 it's
gonna be hard to dislodge that night cuz
you don't actually want to play f4 that
really opens up your king yeah I mean
but you do if you can kick the night out
right yeah so maybe you'll deny c6 I
guess you're there in time to do it
nicely six is looking pretty good
the thing is you're right though because
if four is a move that sometimes you
walk back with the open King it gives
flack the opportunity to consider
exchange Saxon outright but geez except
for except for and not I am starting to
think maybe we should have played up for
we as in as if I have any 67 yes it was
the Queen getting Trevor key 7r okay six
know there's maybe two but it's crazy
right
I think grew shook is taking his time
cuz he wants to make sure he doesn't
miss something better he goes for this
but why be eight and then if he booked a
screen of five say it's a good between
mbm Brooke a seven okay T fives hanging
but actually a five is still good you
might want to lose that d5 yeah cuz it
opens up more lines for both the rooks
and the bishops look at that also my
drawing I think rook one to a 787 right
I like it
he's getting passive on me I don't care
about that D pawn yeah you're right I
like this move because if ninety five
you could gain a tempo put the
bishop on c4 yep I think you were right
I think that was a little bit better but
Kirsch ook without a ton of time is a
little nervous about parting ways with
the D pawn but now it's like at White's
still better I think you can put the
bishop on b5 which holds e8 I honestly
forgot that black doesn't have a pawn
with the exchange even pawns yes that's
right because he was down upon yeah
that's a something I forgot to totally
true which is why I kind of was having
inclination that Oh black should be okay
or not so bad at it in Brooke comes
Steph to 7 is on the agenda guy g3 gives
that Bishop rook up - you invited that
yeah rook takes e5 Oh take that Queen f7
Bishop d3 give it to me game over give
it to me give it to me
Oh even the Queen's off the boards
that's a d7 Bishop c4 c4 first and then
d7 muy bueno a rook a 4 and then Bishop
e6 that would've been funny don't play
d7 right before she takes you 5 patients
oh yeah h4 the King wasn't a choice I
was a pawn on each - on my head I was
like h4 looks good to take the bishops
been a long day for Robert it's uh for
me getting 55 first right yep and then
c4 yeah I don't approve of this
conversion Black's gonna have a blockade
on the dark squares now oh no I think
that was a huge blunder why would he do
that
I think that was a huge flutter I think
winning that game against Dominguez
Perez from the World Cup gave him fall
sectioning c7 this is a draw it was a
horrible decision what why did he do
that are these guys trying to keep this
match close Bishop f4 comes and there's
no win oh my gosh oh my gosh for those
of you who don't know the game I'm
referring to analyzed it for a YouTube
video
Alexander Gerst shook swindled Lanier
Dominguez Perez at the World Cup in
County Mon Sisk about two weeks ago and
won an obstacle defending
should have been a draw and I have a
feeling that he got a little careless
here because absolutely nothing to it he
offers a draw and Wow he's just he's
gotta be so many games have gotten away
from him in this match if you're just
joining us this is just it's been uh I
don't want to use the word poor these
guys are incredibly strong grandmasters
playing amazing chess and we're honored
to commentate on it but it's been it's
been a surprisingly subpar conversion of
advantages for Kruk today rook 65 is a
good decision right he sacrificed an
exchange back we talked about this often
when you're hiding material oftentimes
you may want to sacrifice um to make
this situation easier for your soaps
runclick yeah yeah we'll go back to here
okay well first we'll go here and say
that Bishop d5 for sure the way to play
for a win yeah you're threatening 465 to
remove the guard of the witch it gets a
clean fuel efficient f6 us c4 because
the first line is that the bishop can't
move without the Queen you're just
winning now the rook is cut off you've
got the rooks on the board you'll play
rook e8 and Queen yeah like this is not
us hallucinating rook takes d5 a
completely unnecessary rook to d5 a
completely horrible blunder Bishop to d5
would have been winning yep so that was
the first and maybe last big blunder but
Roberts highlighting that in this
position
Grichuk made the right call to give back
the exchange and go for the attack maybe
we got a little careless to say that the
endgame was easily winning like honestly
the more now that I look at it no I said
what it was great I think I mean you
could try to keep the attack going but
okay let's go with what you what you're
saying you're right okay so we we get
the position with the Queen trade on f7
and should have just been an easily win
again again just stole a second pawn it
was just right just just Bishop e5 and
the game's over
yep and maybe he just missed maybe he
just missed that like Bishop f6 doesn't
threaten anything that might have been
just a quick hallucinate didn't have too
much time left right yeah I mean it's
totally fair but wow I mean this is a
tied match but in some ways due to
missed opportunities as much as it has
been to stellar defense so
see was he so in the chat classic Wesley
hanging out on chess calm after he won
his match yesterday and shocked here
mama drove he said hey tomorrow when I
watch this championship matches you said
you guys are doing a good job and look
there's a diamond member named Soufan
you are my idol that's actually true I
can wait Wesley reported him I report
him resti Wesley reported a stalker
diamond members so fan even if you're a
fan doesn't let you you know you can't
cross lines so if Wesley reported you
you might have had a good reason
just calm is the unlimited amount of
bought people you can block unlike
Facebook take that Mark Zuckerberg this
is real stuff Wesley so block superfan
who's a diamond member thank you for
your support
let's uh let's talk about the game here
this is awesome the the chest comp chat
is lit right now with Wesley so hanging
out and a super fan um well whether
you're whether you're from twitch or
chess TV or chess town thanks for being
here either way so have you look this
position though CC pawns yeah don't
really it's very much confidence in the
pawn structure and now double isolated C
Poland and what you're getting in return
is the open D file your Queen's already
underneath Teresa look after d1 as
possible but at some point black is
going to remove this bishop and aim at
these CC bone so right now can you cheat
may g5 is coming it's actually pretty
annoying I like this plan Queen 795
Bishop of 7uu Knight g5 comes a little
too soon but still Queen 795 I like
black I like what you highlighted I
think positional it could be a bit slow
because if you played Queen e7 I have I
use a queen e six and things like that
Nike six is also possible because you're
not c6 is hanging in many variations so
it seems like white might just be in
time here Queen e6 looks like the right
move I guess our Queen d6 I can't decide
both look good how do I choose I don't
know they both a good shadow to Diamond
member vert which who also hangs out on
twitch but he's a diamond member on
chest calm and he just one guessed the
move and he's not even 1800 well played
or something I don't know what he's
talking about there but thanks for being
here Bruce
um alright 96 there it is the problem is
can I be sure of 7 me pin you and win
you right give you up c64 for East 6 I
kind of like it the thing is I can put
my bishop on d5 so my policy for is not
that weak if my bishop can sit on d5 but
the issue with my bishop run in d5 is at
some point f4 is gonna be a big problem
yeah maybe even right away with laziness
yeah you're not give to verse 26 though
yeah I was thinking the dark squares
might get nasty but you're right why
Russia Bishop c8 first you can't even
attack my rook
no no squares and here comes up for
Bishop g5 what a move
look at our team over whelming the Queen
to hit East 6 depending on the length of
this game I guess it's hard to say this
to be the last one very likely we're
gonna have one more three minute game
after this before bullit commences so
stick around but we only have 5 minutes
and 20 seconds right now on the on the
total clock so just very few games
because they're this match does feel
like we just had another match before it
feels that way but it also feels like
the games have been long you're right
this is looking good for you because you
have rook c8 ago Bishop d7 and say let's
trade on the seventh rank get my rook to
that Square but I'm also still looking
at those CC pawns you just really a CC
pond hater of a CC pawn girl and this is
a CC pawn world they seem like anti CC
bond 56 wins in exchange what would be
six this would be six on the exchange I
missed it to the Batcave there should be
six trap the rook and if you take me I
take you Pokemon these guys are missing
moves all over the board right now maybe
they're as tired as we are that wasn't
good because now I'm a goose on you
agree with you about blacks position and
both of the both bishops they're both
staring down to the pawns okay time to
time to look to take some of the problem
for black is as ugly as those pawns are
you really I mean white is in control
cuz he owns the D file right
so there's not anymore huh rook d8 or
Bishop f6 first perhaps no broker's
rookie threatens to take in win c3
that's true my thought Bishop g5 maybe I
can give up the pawn so everybody soon
find out cuz he's gonna he's gonna call
the bluff or is he if h6 Bishop d2
Brooke d8 with the pin yeah he's
definitely all passive and protected
over at d6 and continue infiltrating on
the D files rook d6 now wonder if he
should have gone for it shook had his
chance
20 seconds to 10 seconds gonna be
another scramble only 3 minutes left in
the middle portion here I like it
ooh III know okay yeah I like you three
a lot take enough - yeah me like it now
if you can get the rooks off the board
you're in great shape the King has to
take because c3 was falling everybody
yeah so rook f6 no then just rook da
roca fate oh he goes for it but that
does might be a draw for okay seems why
falling this but I thought he would try
to play for a win oh but there's no
really from light to go so yeah okay
once more
whoa I just leaned in expecting to say
and as we move to the final game of the
three Minotaur ssin and that turns out I
was wrong but now you may regret that
yeah you may play to lose this he's down
on time and ger shook just got the
coordination he was looking for with the
two bishops focused on their rightful
diagonals taking their place as king Jon
Snow
here we go okay what are 10 minutes
playing to win it seems the odd to me
because they couldn't be because he I
don't think he's any better I agree
now Brooke f6 Obi should be a check as a
threat though so if h5 there's Bishop e8
watch out for that factor would be
pretty nasty rage 5 now I guess HIV
isn't h5 Fischer b6 gay right oh gosh
he's coordinating here comes h5 here
comes the pressure h5 him
this is gonna be a game that our team of
regrets he had his were pretty had his
perpetual okay cookies for its 15 gauge
for a king gauge for why not never try
to do that on chess common that you can
do it's illegal
you were try to do that now I do it all
time oh hung up on down was one pawn
here we go just take with the bishop the
bishop in
g4g for his wedding he missed it he sees
three was a free pond
yeah the G for the Paul was pinned to so
but they're under time pressure hard to
judge right now yeah
two seconds three seconds king g 6r King
G sounds good enough bring the rook into
d3 use the G pawn so you're gonna cheat
the room use the G 3 is a put the king
in the bishop will go d5 sit there for a
bit no but black is winning winning that
sounds strong standing h5 push that pawn
can get four I guess be six we should be
six but there goes rookie - I was just
gonna settle the most fancy peaceful
result we've ever seen he takes a second
to try to think about it and ultimately
can you go King g5 they're deafened
didn't need to settle like back whenever
Sundy - in the Kings even even they're
even there even with ik you know I don't
know give my g3 bond oh yeah what was
Ron King g5 oh yeah there's no takes in
h7 because the work comes to age -
probably I mean they know time you know
it's hard everything blame you didn't
see that you know but know that looks
like it was Bishop h3 is also a deadly
threat rook g8 might just be a big trade
though so hmm right yeah pawn Knight
rook a to a move on and game maybe have
two pawns at the end of that yeah no
you're right but it hasn't been a day of
converting on small advantages what it
has been is one of well I mean honestly
both players get a lot of credit for
being resourceful by creating tricks
pitfalls but it's just it's been
interesting right both players getting
under time pressure there's been a lot
of a lot of swindles a lot of weirdness
yep
so aggression keeps doing the same thing
and I guess our team is welcoming it I
think when go six is the white pieces he
said the two bishops like every single
time seriously he has had the bishop
pair all day for sure time is officially
up here in our three plus one
minute segment which means after this we
will have bullet so don't go anywhere
we may have a tied match heading into
the fastest segment which always keeps
us on the edge of our seat and Wesley so
hanging out in the chest comp shot
calling for moves had Qi for now gonna
move happy grow shook played it and it's
a party going on it's a chess party
today
ain't no party like a chess comm party
because the chess calm party don't stop
d5 is gonna be hanging soon you're
looking at me for I don't know I was
hoping for like hoping you would be my
Mike Dwight Michael Scott right there
see that why do I gotta be Detroit you
can be Michael Scott no too late a fours
always a really good movement yeah
besides on b6 we're never happy to see
that pawn because now that you put upon
a from the p5 so I was gonna say I
thought that even could be three would
be a way to start poking at that but
okay clean qi4 also works they're just
very strategic elements here then be
five squared the knight can jump too but
that 9mb six can't get to b4 and from b5
and i can protect d4 attack these 6 take
away very important squares f5 is coming
in the near future for sure he's gonna
push forward this looks really
unpleasant for black some people hurt
Tim use camera was frozen so I sort of
pay attention and I was a bit about to
say is he frozen and then he did it what
are these very very slight not surely
he's just focused he's very still
doesn't want to waste physical energy on
moving the body or breathing when he's
playing chess okay he's going for the c3
pawn I saw no it's very it's very alpha
zero is very Leela ish the way our Kimia
plays chess right doesn't doesn't fall
in love with the bishop pair loves his
knights willing to kind of mix it up in
the king safety room you know actually
it's at a queen f3
I thought he should want Brooke to be
one and the point is that the senior
problem wasn't really hanging because
Bishop b2 comes taking on a5 and pinning
the knight on B 6 okay so something like
that looked pretty nice yeah black
doesn't have to take c3 that's true but
no I agree that's interesting and you
get that rook into the game
he wants the light squares though that's
the thing well you really do is put that
run from A to D 3 and then black
is toast
so f FG 6 ft 6 Bishop f5 is a
possibility like right now waste like he
might he invited it kind of wait right
now yep do it f takes F takes Bishop a5
Paulus pinned threatening Queen takes h5
yep and rook age 4 runs right in the
bishop takes g6 check the real can see
has been hanging as well but I don't
really care about that no one cares
about the rook on CA like the last kid
picked on the team right here I mean
this is there any way from black to stop
this after FG FG Bishop f5 like his
black just getting toasted like if we
think of what concretely like is there a
single thing the black can do there no
it's I don't know Brooke a - gonna swing
over no not happy about that I mean we
analyzed instead of rook a to just have
like that exact line right takes takes
Bishop a5 how did you deal with it you
would have had to take Queen h5 g 6
right there's 4 cage for at the end oh
that's fine but there's this yeah no
you're right I still think it was great
for white and now we're cage for comes
anyway so not really sure what's going
on here
we've got both sides now with about a
minute remaining on the clock
critical moment critical tension
building up around the g6 trade yep a4
has been hanging now because the rook
moved away from the a2 square but you
have to still consider FG 6th and Bishop
takes c8 so he's inviting this big
change that he doesn't care
no one likes the rook on c8 apparently
he's the true honey badger yeah take
what he wants
yeah actually I'm sorry like blacks
position more now just the control over
the squares they're giving us extra
games here everyone obviously you can
see the clock that means the 3+1 minute
portion is officially over but this game
does count toward the score so just as
critical as every game before it
I was no Bishop II won but then there's
work at four oh wow it's gonna happen oh
he missed it look at his face he totally
missed Rucka for him he jumped yeah
his position is bad now he's losing
exchange well you can still win the
other exchange that's been sitting there
forever so ninety-degree we have played
queen d3 and it takes well but then he
won hangs at the end yeah so he takes
first and queen yes you said you want
hangs in the end yeah games he's just
thrown away amazing positions yeah no
it's this game was particularly
resourceful from our team yeah yeah he's
had the better openings throughout the
day we've been openly critical of our
team gives choice in the first stage but
converting has been has been a struggle
here Frogger shook so if you're just
joining us 7500 of you don't go anywhere
will Sasha find his his top form in the
bullet we're gonna find out here in just
a few moments some questions coming in
in both diamond remember sloppy aya
wants to know who is better and bullet
according to the stats actually don't
know maybe we could bring up the smarter
chess predictions as far as how we
looked at it I don't remember I think
bruh shook was favored slightly bullet
don't you remember but we'll find out
obviously the bullet is coming up and
and there we go yeah gross shook was
favored by just one game in the 1+1
segment but it is also favored by one in
this segment and that's not going that
way no - two for him yeah
anyway so interesting stuff right we'll
see if that storyline pays off if he
does alternately find himself a Ulrika
fork oh our Tim you've takes the lead
not a good series of games there to
bring the three minute to a close for
gazook we will have a very very short
break before we are ultimately gonna
come back for the fastest segment of the
day the doubleheader action here
continues the speech has championship
rolls on don't go anywhere when we
return 1+1 action our Kimia vs. go shook
we'll be right back
[Music]
eight of the most elite chess960 players
on the planet are set to clash in the
feed a world fish a random Chess
Championship quarterfinals beginning
October 4th and ending October 6th
played exclusively on chess calm it's a
game where creativity is king and
memorization is impossible and only one
player will earn the right to call
themselves the king of Fischer random
Vladimir Pharaoh say o ali reza perugia
wesley so Fabiano Caruana Peter Svidler
Yan de pomme the Oishi fitted Gujarati
and Hikaru Nakamura these players will
take center stage as they attempt to
outwit and outclass each other in a
chess variant that many consider to be
the game in its purest form the feet a
world fish a random Chess Championship
quarterfinals will be an event like no
other with over 350,000 dollars in
prizes up for grabs it is the biggest
prize fund for any event in online chess
history will you tune in to witness who
moves on from the quarterfinals to join
Magnus Carlsen and Oslo tune in on the
first weekend of October on chest out
comm TV and twitch.tv slash chest
it's the feed a roll Fisher random Chess
Championship organized by June Deus and
chess calm
and as we get set now for the final
segment of this incredible match between
two of the top players in Russia our
Kimia vs akatsuki we first take a moment
to obviously make a shout out to the
video you just saw the world Fisher
random Chess Championship quarterfinals
will be happening this weekend we're
gonna be deciding who the players are
ago I show them upon shell in the fancy
polite way we don't know the camera but
okay there's a fancy face on the pond no
no big deal my fault we're just super
excited let's remind everybody of the
eight players that have their faces
pasted upon's
Federer say have Spindler Nepal Miyagi
Caruana so Nakamura vidit and firoozeh
I can't wait for this weekend I know
you're pumped but before we get to it
we have bullet we have a one game match
we have a thriller we have seven hours
plus of speech Chess Championship two
matches in one day some said it couldn't
be done
there's naysayers incorrect and what
does Kirk need to do to prove to prove
our Timmy of wrong that he's not gonna
win the match here right now it's just
he just doesn't seem to be as sharp
converting in critical moments we've
seen Sasha play for several years in the
format he normally uses the increment as
well as anybody despite getting himself
in time pressure a lot
he tends to convert when he's better
today there's just been a lot of missed
opportunities for the the veteran from
Russia
maybe he remembers his match last year
against young Christophe Duda where he
was well ahead and Duda came back and
won so it was like I'll be a little bit
behind and I'm gonna kind of come back
and be the talk of the town but on a
serious note
Kirk needs to convert because as we were
just talking about during our break it
seems that Chris Chuck has kind of
botched three four
victorious positions and right maybe
even lost some of those games where as
for Artemyev when he's getting good
positions he's putting Grichuk away at
least that's how it seems so right now
he's only not one game it's still a
toss-up in my eyes and this first game
you know just get on a roll that's
really through the games we'll be
beginning here any moment
and we will have commentary for when
they start we are we are waiting but
yeah I mean I'm just anxious to see
whether Guk can can find himself here in
the fastest portion but obviously our
Timmy if he's here for a reason he was
invited
reason yep rising star if you are one of
the seven thousand viewers with us don't
go anywhere we're getting for a thriller
and again the world fish of random Chess
Championship opening ceremony will be
right after this for the quarterfinals
event so after the bullets segment we
will have interviews and then we will
move right into an opening ceremony
selection like we've never done here
gonna be a blast so stick around don't
go and or stick with us here for the
next couple hours alright alright and
here we have a little CARICOM looking
position but from the Kali and white
trying to gain space on the Queen side
right now we've talked about the c5
square where in several of the games the
Knight d2 is gonna be three the pawn on
a four is gone to a5 and why tries to
gain space and Queen b3 in this case
here what's the point of Queen b3 I
don't know but I do look at the the
graph there above us and we actually
have the heads have flip-flopped now and
then back and forth well I'd be a scary
image and back and forth right there
flip flopping all over the place right
now switch heads in their body yeah the
odds can't seem to continue to predict
based on our pre match predictions so
anyway exciting to see that all right
well answered our question the Queen
went to a3 that was part of the plan
taking over the dark squares mm-hm and
well black is a very solid ever played
b4 you'll have this weakness on the c3
square so that would be kind of a too
quick of a decision I think time
advantage for grew shook as well yeah
small but still I'm 10 second 13 seconds
now it was definitely adding up and
you're just pushing forward here okay I
thought he would just maintain the
tension but no he wants to trade and
play if I do I like that actually and
sounds a small edge for white yeah very
very solid the knight is better for
white than black
now the a6 pawn mm-hmm and b4 is
certainly something to consider we've
seen this structure several times when
you single isolated pawn versus the
black pressure on the B file well I
liked it he's left the pawn b2 because
he was nighttime before at some moment
just it was on the be funnel attack a6
so he'll go rook e1 rook a1 and this is
gonna be problematic yeah I don't know
the crew can hold this one we'll see if
our kami of one of the few games that
were really felt that he missed a win
was one in a very similar structure
where he was white and okay grow shook
finds a way to defend the pawn for now
but isn't okay
I thought 94 was coming it may come next
if you make a trade yeah sort of a satin
for the black knight on b8 I was pointed
out before that it was just a very
passive piece relative to whites active
night and that's honestly what it takes
to get an advantage in this top level is
just having this superior pieces the
rook on d6 passive defending the a6 pawn
the rook on the a1 active hitting that
a6 pawn and now locate Artemia plate on
both sides of the board
he can play pawn g4 to g5 at the right
moment swing his king into g4 and win
this h4 pawn I want to deal a lot I also
like that both sides have been just
completely neck-and-neck here right very
close position we've seen this structure
a few times so that's a nice appropriate
little tip in terms of how we define
that for those wondering what's the real
difference between an open and closed
position there you have it
but okay now gurke has to sacrifice that
pawn the position opening up quickly
here but it may be bad East 6 and rook
f7 is a huge threat yep
I think our Kimi of looking to extend
his lead here we could have our first
two game lead of the match if this one
goes the young Russians way and it looks
like it should go his way but if I was a
mate
luckily it'd be 3 square yeah but 96 and
rook d7 is actually mate yeah okay the
King tries to front 95 to go over c7
check ok this also works you need to
play the Brooke to e2 I
he takes h3 yeah can you get away with
this doesn't look like he's sacrificing
he's gonna try try to hold on with the H
pawn but no no next move dreamin Knight
have two very nice for p1 check it's not
gonna do anything
our Timmy of shows that he may be the
favorite here in the fastest segment
we're gonna find out right we didn't
really know who would be better here but
we do know we have our first two game
lead of the match again until this point
neither player has ever been up by two
games so that's exactly that's how close
this has been and Wow we have this
position again it seems very odd the
bishop goes to e3 blockading the bishop
when f1 in but as we saw in that other
game he went for 95 g3 Bishop g2 at the
right moment and
try to make use of the space strange
line yeah this is just a strange
position yeah I think it is you know
it's a known position where white is
playing for the extra space the the
great Knights compared to this Bishop on
see it especially a great Bishop 1 G 2
and you'll see this rook on H 1 likely
go to there's a d1 but with all these
trades I'm not sure it's gonna get there
in time
yeah it's you know it's active for white
and if you Castle you're kind of
discombobulated there on the Queen side
96 ideas look good rotate should be one
looks good and the a6 pawn still target
so I do prefer White's position in his
eyes and the knight can always go to d3
in any kind of Catalan structure having
tonight on d3 is typically a pretty good
piece protecting a p2 and even line the
pawn and gonna be for later an a6
remains weak especially with the pawn on
a for up before okay
97 I wonder if you're gonna think about
Bishop c6 but that just might be a fancy
trade on something like King e7 so
probably 93 first and then nice e6 so he
gives up the b2 pawn Knight if for is
I'd a 494 rook see one threatening 9 a 4
ok so keeping the options between e4 and
a4 alive he's up this is actually I'm
very impressed with how Christians day
yeah this is by far been the best game
we've seen him have start to finish for
a little while anyway
so Knight a for the move here Brooke to
be one is also tempting just saying that
you're British 1b 7 moves into a
vulnerable spot I'm not sure which one
is better but I think he's just played
quickly sounds obvious you're playing
bullet play quickly but the point is his
time advantage is his biggest asset in
this position and he's still up despite
this huge think right here still 6 5
seconds so all going for d6 take on c5
with why
93 that must be the idea I mean to
otherwise yeah but never be 8 and
there's no way what guards rook c8
there's nothing just should be yeah up a
little bit on the clock but that's his
only advantage left so if something
didn't go well there
should probably be a draw but now you're
all ready now all the sudden for the
first time of the day we have the
gamesmanship conversation starting right
in the Aronian firoozeh match that was a
common sterling Aronian was up so much
he almost blended upon h5 he pushed it
there very early uh but still for it but
aronia was up so much right he wanted to
take time off the clock to prevent the
comeback yeah
for the first time we actually have a
lead for someone and so were you know
you would consider maybe four contender
for that if four is gonna be matter for
nice c5 you still know then you have
rook eight seven check wow I'm a table
big the advantage might have been but it
looked like an opportunity to play on
let's bring up the analysis board and
check that out actually Knight f4
there's not f8 but then rook a seven
wins the cheap on although you can bring
the knight back to d7 it looks a little
uncomfortable but I guess it holds yeah
okay so they settle on the draw yep so
now we have another I said a queen pawn
position Artemia under white says but
this is the first game of the entire
match
I was the isolated Queen bond yeah 22
minutes remaining though so still plenty
of time I mean grow shook himself has
suffered the fate of being up two games
with only six minutes left and actually
lost that match last year to interest of
Duda so certainly this has plenty of
time for either player to make a
comeback or hold on but yeah we're just
not getting wins that's the real problem
yep everyone converting on better
positions period and I remember the last
time he won a game they drew a bunch of
times then it seems like our 10 meters
in winning since then yeah but this this
is a good type of position to try to win
in a bullet game I feel like this
decision by Artemyev to you know play
against the iqp but right now it's at
these little these bishops tearing down
to the Kings side just feels like a nice
setup for black Bishop c5 kicked that
Queen away yeah but now I'm starting to
wonder if there's tactic coming you move
the knight here
Fischer 106 95 okay Brooke c1 put the 92
I think and then play 95 listen you
Danny
and let it happen I like it so we got a
trade Bishop to Bishop should retreat I
think rook takes t7 okay she was just a
little bit no afraid I get afraid to
Bishop e7 now Knight c3 no 94th Bishop
backs up there's a seventh rank
happening and I like it I don't like
laying them Bishop c8 here you stood up
there should be six coming next so maybe
Knight b5 is a move why should consider
yeah stop a ship d6 hit a 795 looks like
a very good native a6 you might even
have 97 who does yep
what the heck Bishop should be sick lose
the d5 pawn damn this so you just wrong
idea
b7 is gonna fall you can't even play h3
first if you want just to force them out
a g5 oh yeah maybe he should wait for
what oh and if working 103 in 92 you
didn't see it nice - very nice tactic I
think he should have played the move h3
that we were talking about earlier this
was super awkward but the bishop gets
trapped rookie for save it or 94 good
night good night for f3 okay over the
nice d6 or something actually 94 you can
play 96 so I thought he would have
played 96 there what age 7 Knight a5
no fork town oh no less there's
something crazy Chris tricks about to go
down 3 games he's losing this one should
have played 96 no dye takes doesn't do
any it doesn't do anything nothing I
know how many shakes his head he's going
down 3 games there's nothing to it down
a rook and there's no tactics resign and
move on right you still have plenty of
time to come back but it's getting away
from you getting away we have New Kids
on the Block right
you have Russian blood here and the
youngster might be about to upset the
speech Chess Championship veteran and
Alexandre shook anchor sugars not one
since game 12 no wonder I couldn't
remember that's that isn't we're now 19
games in he hasn't won since game 12 7
games plus in fact maybe maybe eight
games now that last one just finished
yeah it's been bad news for sure but
well he still chances
what is this night on d7 knight on c6
situation what is that
it looks terrible was it like somehow
I'm I yeah I don't get it
maybe it's gonna turn out okay but it
looks very very strange be six oh six do
it
who cares about be too seriously play
six there it is
so I'm talking about that's what I'm
talking about forget B to forget it yep
keep going it's not you play for a win
this is perfect bullet grow shook means
a victory to get back in this thing
I mean Captain Obvious damn right but we
know all right
I think but this is the kind of attack
you got 94 coming castles Bishop to g5
put a piece on f6 let's go right to c7
pawns hanging if you just want to steal
a pond at some point Knight g5 options
so what's he thinking about here oh wait
you don't want to love castles long so
take c7 now I was single so 94 to c5 but
okay you just oh yeah
give me that 94 now over Jeter's hanging
yeah but c7 hangs mm-hmm yeah I don't
know which they're casting a smart now
94 okay he's 6 C 6 95 some kind of queen
a3 might be 505 was just winning upon
well c6 you couldn't take an 87 because
you never doing trap okay yeah but a4 is
always a nice move I thought I could
take him Queen C 5 okay yeah but this is
nice and you have a 5 coming in Queen C
5 maybe Queen C 5 first you can threaten
Queen a 7 yep I think that might have
been a little trickier but he goes for
85 so that 25 is also kind of
trapped at E 4 is a might be a threat
but after a 4 then bc 5 for block it's
getting battling anyway right and if you
even if you pin it king moves off and
yuri knew the threat 9a for archenemy of
has wiggled his way out yet again yep
restrictors had a consistent time
advantage at the first couple stages of
be full at games but still has lost all
of them neither of three to d4 but the
night's gonna kind of c5 for black
that's not fun
arc in me have working it again yep
amazing right now we want it we want to
see the
the close finish here Booker shook is
gonna have to breathe life into his own
chances yeah it's not going well from it
all blacks up upon the past see palm
which means the queen or a lot of time
could come off the clock in this game
right here this is one of those danger
games danger Alexander grishnack will be
six remember 94 those tactic whoa whoa
what always whoopsie 100 that's nasty
but Queen d2 does it or queen d1 doesn't
matter if he's got 24 so Brook takes b3
there's recent one I think he's fine
he's got Queen d4 check okay okay I
guess
ooh very nice of course the Queen's off
the board black is winning because these
two pawns are super fast so we're trying
to get a passed pawn real quick you know
go f4 of and sharing it at five in and
push those pawns
very nice this is this is not bad by
crook because g4 forcing the King to
become open if you ever wanna play b5
right Queen e2 whoa okay three rook D
for Queen b5 I think this could be the
match right here Queen C flag is playing
so accurately our Kim you have up on the
clock about to win and take a four game
lead it's quickly 61 and it's over yeah
Kim oh my gosh that's one of those games
it's a bit of a backbreaker or shirk now
down four points total with only 15
minutes remaining
the young guns have come to play he just
can't buy a victory I mean that was
begging me didn't really deserve victory
but he tried to get things pretty crazy
there he sat in exchange he had
opportunities earlier and I wonder if
he'll you know if he'll recognize that
obviously we'll have conversations with
them after the match and ask him if he
feels like he you know let some of the
games get away from him you know early
on if you if he even sees it the way we
do he may not even be aware that he
missed some clear wins like this night
before game comes tomorrow right but
okay obviously we know Gersh York loves
the speech s championship so he's not
gonna go down without a fight
we'll see if he can pull it together
right now but look wow
yeah it's hard to same thing as we both
you know we're not rooting for anybody
but we know Sasha well he's been
competing and trying very hard over the
last bunch of years he really prepares
for the matches and this one's just not
going his way and it feels like he's had
so many good chances you know it's just
yeah so many good chances are timmy of
though stone-cold killer has hardly
hardly moved honestly be like like
physically his body has hardly moved all
right well this game also looks really
good for our Jamie and honestly good
position for white not a ton of time
left
yeah this you know needs to take this
one somehow but if you take on d6 and I
take with my bishop when d6 then I'm
happy but this exchange here the knight
has a great blockade on d6 the Knights
of the best block haters they're very
hard hard to dislodge and if you ever
take on that 540 back with my knight now
it's even worse obvious because you're
walking into a fork but in general I
just take my Knight f5 and then just
continue blocking your pawn dark square
you have a light square bishop Wow
oh no just looking at chat getting the
hype up there's some kind of sore I got
my arm keep rubbing it just sharing how
I feel with everyone I don't know but
this to me I look at this position yeah
you highlighted blacks got the setup
with the block a but I just feel like
this is uh this is a tough position to
try to win within the next couple
minutes yeah this is looking tougher and
tougher for for Gersh ook and time is
running out don't take it Queen takes d6
oh he's just like he's falling apart
he's falling apart that might be the
moment of the match right there that was
a backbreaker and I think I think we can
pretty much call it after that yeah so
although it was a five game deficit for
ali reza with about this much time left
okay right it's just the momentum was
totally different right it was eight
games that had come to five games yeah
a one-game headed into bullet now five
games for our Jimmy of Wow Timmy is now
bopping look at him yeah he's enjoying
it a little bit he's finally showing a
little bit of emotion
recognizing that he's he's in a
commanding position right now in the
match just a beast right now can't be
stopped
won't be stopped can't stop won't stop
hey Larissa hanging out in the chat wait
what
I don't know what he's talking about
well we're glad he's here
wait where did Boyd's beep on just go
that's yeah where'd it go I turn away
for a second with the people everything
about this is normal but the b-pawn is
gone
and now it's starting to look bad once
nice III picked up an exchange Oh
they've broken it's not actually not
quite trapped though got 876 oh no
longer on the board though so what's the
situation here the eight-balls good is
the even material Wow after all that's
even material there was like a weird
imbalance things were all over the place
'if I've almost traps that bishop but
his age six to go do so the bishop
closed off that a pawn is so strong yeah
Queen b3 gonna be met by rook b8 mini
six Knight takes c2 overwhelms the
Queen's defence grow shook is on full
tilt here I think when this one Falls
it's uh g5
can you play g5 to remove that bishop
from the defense of e5 take that pawn
get a great Bishop okay now you can't go
g5 of course but again this is this is
this is super tough we can see a lot of
time ago off the clock here yep
yeah this is not good now he fives
hanging such a strange finish to the
match this is this is the anti Aronian
furusho match right yeah an eight-game
lead at one point for Levon Aronian ends
in a single game victory that felt like
he barely got away with it I think the
clock ended just in time for Aronian not
to lose Yeah right and in this case it
was a very very close match throughout
before we got to bullet neither player
had ever led by more than one game if
you happen to just be joining us and
with that go shook has not won a single
game in the final segment obviously you
see the score it is now a six-point lead
for Vladislav artemiev I can't wait for
postgame interviews I guess I mean it's
gonna be a little bit hard right for for
Sasha Griffith we know how much he cares
about this but Wow Grandmaster Wesley so
artemiev is an ultra killer right what I
said yeah he's my he's ruthless
maybe maybe Wesley's listening probably
stole your line Wesley you know when we
had to pick one of the players in this
toss-up matchup I was like you know I
got to go with our team you yeah you did
you did but we both thought it would be
a closer than this I thought restricts
experience would hold off and to be fair
I think I think there were a lot of
games that could have gone the other way
in the slower time controls and I wonder
if at some point the wind went out of
his sails when he just wasn't converting
several good positions and and if that
if that had any kind of hangover or
affective future games so but either way
we will catch up with the players in
only eight minutes so don't go anywhere
let's remind everybody while we have
them that the Fisher random world chess
championship opening ceremony is right
after the interviews we will have a fun
little way of deciding who plays who and
who gets white first so the players will
the players don't know because because
nobody does it's gonna be a random
drawing that's about to happen probably
about thirty minutes exactly from now we
will know who's playing who so don't go
anywhere gonna be a ton of fun and
thanks for being here all of you it's
been quite today yep and I see Saba
can't really see at esli some of the
dances Artemia beat a car in class
oh that is true in Gibraltar when our
tentative won the event he beat many
strong players and was too much of a
surprise attend me it was rated you know
and you know there's a reason he got an
invite
he didn't even qualify his way in I mean
we invited him we recognized you know
the potential future of where this kid
is headed and invited him
obviously he's he's moved on here to the
second round so amazing stuff eaten -
since his last loss eaten - he's come a
role meeting six wins and four draws he
hasn't lost 10 games and this thing
sometimes you know there this let's say
you make four draws or two wins and two
losses it just feels good to win a game
just that taste of victory and Chris
Chuck hasn't taste that in a long long
time yeah too long too long for my taste
and doesn't look like he's gonna get
this one either is rooked a c6 some kind
of meat it's happening it's happening
also 92 94 could be a slight problem
what is it it's just mate check rook f6
and mate you just resigns rook FC that's
mate no it's mate on the board there's
that even really my guess that's me and
you're like oh it's gonna be maybe with
rook up six weeks I'm like
overcomplicating and well there you go
oh man thanks for being here everybody
and quite the day well there you have it
Ladislav our gym you have runs away with
the match the one moral victory we all
have is that smarter chess was wrong
yeah we could all bond in that you're so
correct thank you for reminding me yeah
given Robertson ammunition I can't wait
to see smarter chess reply to that but I
don't know by the way to be fair to Matt
how does he make predictions when like
our team has never played before right
it's like it's super difficult no
experience don't give him any excuses
come on you know the there he is
this is the 60% the 60% favorite
Alexandra kirkuk according
to our stats and honestly according to
myself as well that's the way I saw this
match to be fair jokes aside we're just
teasin our team Ian pulls an upset here
I mean the problem is according to the
seeds he was not the underdog he was the
six seed coming in in terms of feed a
blitz rankings and he does move on as
the favorite so with only five minutes
left and a seven-point lead we've
officially pretty much called the match
but like I said don't go anywhere the
players will be with us soon
interviews Chuck Norris jokes will ask
Alexandre shook why he calls vladislav
archenemy of the Chuck Norris of Russia
that'll be a fun story if you're also
hilarious if I just made that up you
know I was like oh he calls him that
started a rumor isn't true I would
believe that you did something like that
I'm pretty positive I sought an article
by Peter dockers the one and only Peter
daggers the one and only yeah mr.
talkers yeah exactly correct
pronunciation Stoker's pretty good pants
Dockers towards threat because ninety
four needs a defense the d5 pawn do you
might wanna play rook c8 there it is
alright just take that pony take it but
now what's he gonna do a movie tend to
want to play now rookie for sex the
exchange
do it do it I've been putting my back
into it and heard 64 do it no Brooke
take your back into it
I told you I did it hurts so the truth
is exactly that's always gonna happen
now you find a cheap profit once said
you can do it put your back into it
Kings on g4 nights coming to s6 it
doesn't matter Kings gonna run back to
h3 I love the Queen G to move though I
felt very alpha zero like yeah
like g4 though look how dangerous these
two pieces are there too good
take that 95 just do it King there I
think you make a draw losing streak ends
that's good some great insights there
yep
and I'm gonna guess our next game is the
last game probably time for one more
there we go
much to the chagrin of ours an aggressor
who would probably like to resign the
match yeah as we know so I was thinking
about that when you like goes into talks
about to be fair the last time he
brought up the idea that we allow them
he was in the line she was in the
winnings yeah so not not quite the same
and of course every game is worth a
little bit of cash money so not as much
money as the each game is worth
throughout the event right with every
with every round the amount of prizes go
go significantly higher but but still
every game worth a little bit of money
at this point
yep maybe our timmy of Angra sure can
buy some nice wall nice wall art they do
have very white walls there yep
so black singh on h5 at some point 9 f8
to h7 Knight to g5 kind of stuff white
is gonna open up the C file try to make
progress there
that's my insight for this game
that's deep mmm so deep let's go Brooke
c1 next Queen a5 okay I thought when
your five would have a nice slaw yeah
but now Queen c5 meets okay so 96 stops
that but you have 94 coming true hmm
there's night afore he hasn't lost
Vladislav has not lost any very long
time he just doesn't know how to lose he
doesn't know how can't blame him for not
losing right oh that connects go to g3
put a pony there I like it there's
absolutely no attack for black and the C
files white for the taking you should
sack the Queen for a rook and Bishop
just to bring this thing to a close I
mean I would have been down for it okay
here comes rook c8 now I gotta guard the
B cell a5 Bishop takes a6 as possible
though ooh it was anyway nice Bishop we
should be five but never trapped yeah I
hanging but b2 to beat a Gumby three up
on this is the last game for sure ten
seconds left
the official game clock has pretty much
aligned with that no way this game is
ending here smarter chess Vladislav has
not lost since Wesley so join the game
chat when it was six to six that there
could be a real stat you never know yeah
you never know it was smart chess what's
real and what's just what's real what's
not right what he's tracking what he's
not does he work for the NSA does he not
questions we asked around the yeah well
just calm office on a regular saw and
with it the draw brings us to a close
here the match is officially over it has
been here in a surprising run away
performance in the bullet I don't know
why the next game started I think they
will
abort it and we have officially reached
our close with the score being what you
see before you 16 to 9 in favor of
vladislav our Timmy of the young blood
take it home we will take a very quick
break when we return interviews then
official random World Chess Championship
quarterfinal opening ceremony don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
a Premium Membership at chess comm we'll
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50000
puzzles to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you play turning every game into a
chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level and
we are back now with the 2019 speed
chess championship our two players have
just joined us thank you again Vladislav
and alexander for a great match sasha we
wanted to start with you it it seemed to
us as commentators that there were a lot
of games in the early portion both the
five-minute and the three-minute that
just that just kind of got away from you
where you were pushing and maybe have
missed opportunities did did you feel
that way that you were missing chances
to convert on on winning games or did
you not see it like that you alexander
we thought that you had some games that
you were winning early on and it seemed
like you lost a little bit of of energy
not not converting on some games that
you should have won earlier well what
did you see your chances we're headed in
- boy you were down a game against
vladislav and what were your thoughts
before the match started as far as how
you would fare in the one once portion
vladislav oh well you did that just
barely just barely
by seven points
wladislaw did you consider yourself a
favorite I think that this much was
interesting but still we do a many
mistakes and those I think that the
first part or much was more correctly
because one complete control and okay
Alexander one is a little much
maybe it's not more but okay we play
tools uncompromising and it was a real
battle I think here but ok I think that
in this much you not have a favorite my
opinion and I think that it's it's true
Vladislav did you figure that you would
be the big favor in bullet because you
seem to you know take charge in the
quickest time control and one most the
games there I not remember every game
but when when we finish too much it was
real crazy cinema I think is good
sometimes but not all games it's a
difficult analysis because very many
games maybe maybe interesting moment was
white pieces Alexander can play tonight
H - I missed my phone on H - when I
played in c3 yes it's still a mistake
but example also not see - can i play -
III
later you play it is not yes I do fun
like you can I hope that France look are
much with smile smiles but great much
but ok I think that I not was is better
than Alexander maybe I was more likely
today we appreciate that Alexander
question for you you you you told Peter
talkers in an interview that you
thoughtful Addis thought was a Chuck
Norris no no I
so why do you why do you say he's the
Chuck Norris of of Russian chess no it
didn't go your way this year but we
really appreciate it we love having you
and you've been you've been a fan
favorite for a lot of people on chess
calm for a long time so again thank you
thank you so much and really appreciate
it Vladislav before we let you go the
quarterfinals are now complete you will
be facing Levon Aronian this was the
last match so how do you think you stack
up against the Armenian yes yes I go in
the second round but I don't know who
will be my opponent
but probably it will be such strong
player it'll be it'll be Aronian it'll
be Aronian in the second round
I don't wanna yes yes mm-hmm
he's interesting my chicken here yeah
Sasha who you got Sasha who's gonna win
that match Aronian or Artemyev religious
laughs is a favor
let's see okay thank you thank you thank
you both guys I really enjoy your night
we know it's late there and
congratulations again falada Slaven
thank you again Alexander okay okay
thank you and everybody thank you
well there we have it our players are
checking out now we've got the
quarterfinals complete as we can see the
bracket has officially reached the
second stage with Vladislav Artemyev
defeating Alexandra shook by a final
score of 16 to 9 as you can see right in
front either so anyway obviously a
little bit tough for for Sasha of course
we asked him I didn't want to dig dive
deeper into the earlier stages of the
match because he probably doesn't even
know yet that he was winning in several
games and that's okay right obviously
it's a tough situation but somebody from
Russia had to move on it was our timmy
of this time and as sasha said he's the
Chuck Norris of Russia's because he's
strong and he's cool well and he also
proved himself very worthy of the invite
to the speechless championship he made
his mark I don't think many people
expected this match to be his lobster in
score as it was yep and Artemyev ever
modest was saying that you know as an
equal match I was lucky and you know
that's just a lot of modesty I think
that as he was holding games be more and
more resourceful they definitely got
undercooked skin yeah he ended up you
know faltering but first in the
three-minute segment then the one-minute
was a domination it really a masterclass
by our team even you know he said that
he's an interesting match with Aronian I
totally agree yeah hi right now I
couldn't tell you who I had favored
based on that performance
Gertrude thinks of laddus loves the
favor yeah I honestly I have to agree
because what are Tim Tim showed in the
bullet today was much better than what
LaVon showed in the bullet against
firoozeh and I don't think that Artemyev
is gonna be down seven games at any
point of that match so yeah if all the
Rays that almost came back and won that
that's smells like trouble for LaVon
okay well it was super interesting and
the speech has championship first round
is officially in the books and it's time
for us to
to make our way from one chess event to
another with this opening ceremony that
you're about to watch the world official
random Chess Championship quarterfinals
officially begin we're gonna take a very
very short break so that we can get set
up when we come back we will have all of
the players before us believe it or not
they're all just waiting outside the
door they're just gonna come in here all
the players and we're gonna tell them
who they're gonna play so don't go
anywhere the world Fisher random Chess
Championship opening ceremony begins in
just a few minutes